Fock, ja heute mal 10 Minuten früher als sonst, wartet mal kurz, wartet mal kurz, mit dem Headset nicht
wartet mal kurz, ja jetzt ist besser, mal kurz entwirren, ja jetzt ist besser, exellent ist das, exellent oder auch nicht
mal kurz muten, so jetzt besser, so moin, Twitch sagt ich habe null Zuschauer, Chat ihr zählt nicht
was ist da los, nicht dick genug, kann Twitch die User nicht zählen
bei dir steht 42, bei mir steht 0, ah Refreshen, vielleicht geht es dann, jetzt steht bei mir 30, exellent, exellent
ja jetzt scheint es zu funktionieren, na gut, ich muss euch mal wirklich Painz Champions zeigen, ich habe ja gestern ein bisschen umgebaut
bei mir, Netzwerkkabel in den Keller gelegt vom ersten Stock aus, ich sage euch, es war schwieriger als ich mir das vorgestellt habe
ich habe das ja schon im Stream angekündigt, dass ich das machen will, also ich habe hier hinten, ich versuchte es euch nur mal kurz für die letzten Stream nicht dabei waren zu erklären
was ich versucht habe, also, das hier ist das Video von dem Serverraum, wo es hier so unordentlich ist, aber das ist eigentlich ganz gut
hier hinten habe ich einen Kabelkanal, leider ist er in diesem Video komplett zugedeckt, man sieht ihn nicht, also hier hinten ist ein Kabelkanal
da kommen Kabel raus aus dem Erdgeschoss und aus dem Keller, die Sache ist nur die, das Kabel was in den Keller ging, muss ich euch das zweite Video zeigen
also ich habe, ja hier sieht man es, hier sieht man es wunderbar, ich habe nur ein Kabel was in den Keller geht von diesem Raum
das ist ein K7 8 Adern Patch Kabel, so ein ganz normales grünes Ding, gut ich fahre jetzt jetzt egal, also ich habe hier ein Kabel durchliegen
aber Massive Brained haben die Typen, die das gebaut haben, sich gedacht, weil ich habe denen gesagt, hey ich will meinen Telekom Anschluss, ich will den Telefon Anschluss
will ich hier haben, ich will nicht jedes Mal in den Keller, falls ich mal irgendwie Router neu starten muss oder sonst irgendwas, damals habe ich noch nicht an wireless Steckdosen gedacht
also die haben gedacht, also ich habe denen gesagt, ich brauche einen Netzwerkkabel und ich will die, also ich brauche mindestens einen Kabel Keller Serverraum
und ich will die Netzwerkdose, die Telefondose will ich hier oben haben, nicht im Keller, also was haben die gemacht, die haben das wörtlich genommen, was ich ihnen gesagt habe
die haben den Netzwerkkabel gelegt, also sieht ja von innen so aus, so sieht das ja von innen aus, du hast da halt 8 Adern drin und ziemlich genauso, so sieht das auch aus
ich habe auch extra shielded und sonst was, du hast da 8 Adern drin und jetzt haben sie Big Brain Time gemacht, sie haben, richtig weird champ, sie haben einfach 2 Adern Paare von diesen 8
genommen für die Telefondose, das Problem ist nur, Chet wer ist so schlau, wer weiß wieviel Adern braucht man für Gigabit
wieviel Adern braucht man für Gigabit, 8, genau, richtiger 5 hat moment, also sie haben im Endeffekt das gemacht, was ich wollte, Netzwerkkabel und Telefondsteckdose angeschlossen
nur, dass sie es so gemacht haben, dass ich nichts davon verwenden kann, also was habe ich gemacht, ich bin hier hin, habe das aufgemacht, habe die Telefondose rausgebaut
habe das Kabel abgeschnitten, bin in den Keller runter, habe das dort abgeschnitten von dem Gegenstück von der Telekom, ich brauche das Ding gar nicht, ich bin ja komplett über Unity Media und VoIP, ich habe ja keinerlei Telekom Zeug bei mir im Einsatz
so, dann hatte ich ein Kabel mit 8 Adern drinnen und der Mist liegt auch nicht im Leerrohr, ne, aber das ist mit meine Schuld, weil ich nicht explizit gesagt habe, macht mal Rohre, auf der anderen Seite, ja
ja, gut, auf der anderen Seite hätte man auch sagen können, ey, wir machen das auch so, aber egal, ja Leerrohr ist nicht so angesagt, Hyper Subscription hier, ich finde das ordentlich
komm mal Gento installieren, ne, habe ich öfters zugeguckt und das will ich nicht selbst machen, ich hatte einen Kollegen auf der Arbeit, der war damals der Meinung, er muss Gento installieren und er hat gefühlt 2 Tage gebraucht bis es lief, dass sein Netzwerktreiber in der VMA funktioniert hat
eigentlich ist das eine witzige Idee, das könnte man echt mal machen, das könnte man echt mal machen
so, also, was ich jetzt gemacht habe ist unten abgeschnippelt, so und dann habe ich den Rad vom Chat befolgt und habe mir einen Keystone AJ45 Stecker gekauft, also einen 4er Pack, solche Dinger und die habe ich dann oben und unten drauf gemacht
und dann ist mir aufgefallen, ich habe ja sogar, also richtig massive Brain Chat, so sieht das aus, genau, so sieht das aus, du fädelst hier, du fädelst hier die einzelnen Adern ein, dann steckst du das quasi kopfüber da rein und machst den Stecker zu und dann, hier sind kleine Messer drin und es schneidet sich dann selbst in das Kabel rein und stellt Kontakt her, das ist eigentlich ziemlich nice
war mir zwar irgendwie bewusst, dass es das gibt, aber nie so wirklich 100% klar, bevor das der Chat nochmal empfohlen hat, also muss man sagen, richtig massive Brain Chat, so, also habe ich jetzt so ein Ding auf die eine Seite gemacht, also hier oben und auf die andere Seite im Keller
und dann ist mir eingefallen, ich habe ja noch einen Kabeltester, so ein Ding, so einen ganz billigen China-Chinesen-Kabeltester, also das billigste was es gibt, sowas hier, das ist quasi das China-Chinesen-Kabeltester-Teil, wo man den Kabeltester vorher wahrscheinlich erstmal testen muss, ob er richtig testet
zumindest, ich habe einfach ein normales Netzwerkkabel durchgestöpselt und habe den eingeschalten, es funktioniert, das ist die einfachste Variante überhaupt, es leuchtet einfach hier die 1, 2, 3 nacheinander und du musst einfach gucken, ob alle Lichter leuchten, das ist der low-brainigste Kabeltester aller Zeiten
für das SS habe ich übrigens keine Ahnung, vielleicht Reverse oder so, ich weiß, keine Ahnung, oder vielleicht für das AJ11, zumindest, zumindest, habe ich das oben und unten dran gemacht und habe den Kabeltester angeschlossen
und es hat geplinkt auf 1, 2, 3 nicht, 4, 5, 6, 7 und 8 auch nicht
so und dann hatte ich das Problem, wo ist jetzt der Fehler, oben oder unten, also in welchem Stecker habe ich es verkehrt gemacht, oben oder unten, also habe ich mir gedacht, komm wenn du gerade schon im Keller bist, wenn du schon im Keller bist, machst du den Stecker im Keller einfach nochmal neu
also habe ich den Stecker im Keller neu gemacht, also nochmal abgeschnitten, im Keller hatte ich auch mehr Kabel noch übrig, weil ansonsten das Kabel hier oben, das geht hier quasi durch und es ist nicht mehr so viel Platz
so also Stecker neu gemacht, im Keller, wieder angeschlossen, immer noch, immer noch auf dem Kabeltester 3 und 8 falsch, aber ich werde ok, 2 mal gleich falsch unfähig anschließen werde ich nicht sein, der Fehler liegt oben am Stecker, also bin ich hoch und habe den letzten Zentimeter, quasi den ich habe, dass ich es in die Dose bekomme noch
ne, ne Tester ist nicht kaputt, Tester ist nicht kaputt, also der hat schon funktioniert, ich habe ja mit dem anderen Kabel vorher getestet, das ging, so also oben hin, hier hin, das hing dann hier noch raus, ok, neu dran gefehlt, Kabeltester angestöpselt, funktioniert, nice
so und dann habe ich big brain move gemacht, ich habe mir hier eine Netzwerkdose drauf gesetzt, die erste Netzwerkdose, die ich je im Leben selbst gesetzt habe, also ich habe im Endeffekt einfach diesen TEE, diese TEE Blende abgemacht und habe eine Netzwerkdosen Blende draufgemacht mit einem Klipser für so einen Keystone
und jetzt habe ich hier eine Netzwerkdose mit einem Anschluss, wo Keller drauf steht, danach habe ich es aber mega verkackt, das ist das, wo ich Mist gekauft habe, heißt Johee, Dankeschön für 12, nein 20 massive Subscription Monate, so und dann habe ich eine Sache echt verkackt, ich habe mir doch letztens, ich habe mir doch letztens im Switch so ganz zackig den billigsten Mikrotik Switch gekauft, der PoE kann, nämlich den hier
weil von der Idee her wollte ich das so machen, ich schließe hier unten, nehme ich ein Kabel hin, mache das dann hier hoch, an die Dose gehe in den Keller, Wasseresser, Dankeschön für den Prime Sub, funktioniert ja auch wunderbar und unten dachte ich mir, das ist ja ein PoE Router hier oben, unten dachte ich mir, mache ich den PoE Switch dran
von Mikrotik, der hat nämlich PoE in und PoE out und meine Idee war, ich kann den Router über PoE betreiben, den Switch über PoE betreiben und den Access Point, da habe ich nämlich so ein Ding für den Keller, so und ich dachte mir, ich mache einfach Stromversorgung komplett
komplett übers Netzwerkkabel, also Kabel runtergezogen, dann nochmal ganz zum Glück, sonst hätte ich das Ding wahrscheinlich gegrillt, nochmal reingeguckt in die Specs von diesem Switch und da ist mir aufgefallen, der kann nur Input 11 bis 30 Volt, aber PoE ist 48 Volt, also ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was das hier für ein komisches PoE sein soll, wahrscheinlich 24 Volt PoE, was auch immer
zumindest, mein ganzes PoE und auch die Geräte dran sind 48 Volt, das heißt, ich habe mir dieses Ding komplett umsonst gekauft und ich habe jetzt keinen Switch im Keller, das heißt, ich konnte genau ein Gerät anschließen und das ist mein Access Point, aber das hat funktioniert, aber das war ein 55 Euro umsonst rausgeschmissenes Geld, weil das überhaupt nicht das macht, was ich will, aber ich behalte den trotzdem, weil Switche braucht man immer mal, scheiß auf PoE vor allem
Scheiß auf PoE Funktionalität, ja das habe ich ein bisschen verkackt, aber das hat viel länger gedauert, als ich gedacht habe, ich habe da bestimmt 3 Stunden gestern herum gewurstet, bis dieses Kabel von hier, anstatt dass es jetzt hier eine Netzwerkdose ist, in den Keller geht, richtig, richtig painstjammt gewesen
Ja, und wo ich dann gerade mal im Keller war, habe ich mich mal wieder, wir gucken übrigens gleich Zeug, ich muss jetzt mal ein bisschen erzählen, weil es mich gestern so angepainstjammt hat, habe ich gedacht, ok, wenn du mal im Keller bist, machst du mal Fotos von deinen ganzen Geräten im Keller
Und ich habe es ja schon lange vor, meine Tür-Gegensprechanlage mit den Telefonen zu verbinden, ich habe da auch schon verschiedene Anläufe gemacht, aber es hat alles nicht richtig funktioniert und ich habe jetzt mal ein paar Fotos gemacht von den Geräten, die ich da habe, also sprich, was das für eine Gegensprechanlage ist und was das für Telefone sind als Gegensprechding im Flur
So, und da ist mir aufgefallen, ok, das einfachste ist, die haben was Neues von dem Hersteller, die haben jetzt, also ich habe so Dinger an der Wand hängen für Tür-Gegensprechanlage, so komische Telefone, so und was ich jetzt von dem Hersteller, passt mal auf, jetzt wird es richtig, richtig painstjampig
Es ist schon richtig weirdchamping, was die da wieder treiben, so ich habe jetzt gelesen, die einfachste Variante, also ich habe jetzt was Neues seit letztem Jahr, da muss man gar nichts mehr basteln, die einfachste Variante ist einfach so eine Gegenstelle von der Tür-Gegensprechanlage durch eine IP-fähige Gegenstelle auszutauschen
Gibt es von denen, sieht genauso aus, nur dass es das WLAN-Stell am Start ist, so, dachte ich mir, eigentlich eine coole Idee und dann habe ich mir das mal angeguckt und ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen, die haben eine gute Idee, wirklich maximal verkackt umgesetzt
Ich weiß nicht, was mit den Herstellern los ist, also von der Idee her schließt du das hier einfach dort an, also erstens ist es saumäßig teuer, jetzt kommt es ja, also guckt euch mal den Preis an, erstens, das ist das billigste vom Billigen an Plastik-Analog-Gegensprechanlage überhaupt
Es war 250 Euro, okay, okay, meinetwas, aber jetzt kommt der Hit, es ist wirklich maximal painstampig gemacht, von der Idee her ist es einfach, du nimmst dein altes Tür-Gegensprechsystem, steckst das ab, steckst das Neue dran, so, die zeigen ja auch, ja wunderbar, kannst du aufs Smartphone anrufen, so jetzt kommt aber der Hit
Ihr habt sich gedacht, das wäre viel zu einfach, wenn man das Ding einfach konfigurieren könnte, mit jedem x-beliebigen Zip-Gateway-Volp-Gedöns sprechen zu können
Dass man da einfach ein Setting rein macht, dass man sagt, hey, connecte dich zu, was weiß ich, Zip-Gate, Easybell, was auch immer, oder connecte dich zur Fritzbox, oder vielleicht sogar ein analogen Telefon-Out oder so, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, das wäre viel zu einfach gewesen
Das einzige, mit dem diese Dinger funktionieren ist, die offizielle App über die offiziellen Server vom Hersteller
Also, du kannst dieses Ding nicht verwenden mit einer Fritzbox, mit irgendeinem x-beliebigen Zip-Anbieter, du kannst nur über die offiziellen Server das machen und du kannst das nur über die offizielle App verwenden und nur auf Android und IOS
Also an Deck-Telefone oder so, dass die Telefone im Haus klingeln, weiterleiten, geht damit gar nicht, du könntest dann höchstens das irgendwie vom Telefon oder so vielleicht weiterleiten, keine Ahnung
Und du bist angewiesen auf die Server des Herstellers, sprich, wenn dein Internet nicht geht, dann klingeln auch deine ganzen Telefone nicht, also es ist jetzt nicht irgendwie so mit Deck-Telefone, es ist so unglaublich bescheuert, warum baut man denn sowas?
Nein, ich weiß warum man sowas baut, weil Wendor log in, was sonst? Aber es ist einfach nur weird champ, wie man so einen Müll bauen kann, an sich eine richtig gute Idee, 250 Euro fucking teuer, aber es funktioniert einfach nicht so wie man das haben will
Wo ist das Problem? Guck mal, ich mein, das Ding kann Bluetooth und WLAN, man könnte WLAN, man könnte Config über Bluetooth machen, ok, man könnte einfach Config über ein Webinterface machen, man gibt seinen ZIP Gateway ein und es funktioniert
Nee, warum sollte Deckt aussterben? Also AVM hat was dagegen, dass Deckt aussterbt, die machen ja ganze Smart Home Zeug über Deckt, aber es ist einfach fail, das hat mich so abgefuckt, weil ich mir gedacht habe, hey, das wäre die einfachste Variante, das wäre die einfachste Variante gewesen, das VoIP technisch anzuschließen
Aber nein, der Hersteller denkt sich mal wieder, Wendor log in ist wichtiger als sinnvolle Funktion
Hey, Smuzzin, ich weiß nicht, kennst du dich mit sowas aus? Kennst du dich mit sowas aus? Weil ich hab lustigerweise genau das gleiche gefunden und mal vorhin auf Ebay geguckt und auf Ebay gibt es die Dinger sogar relativ, relativ günstig
Kann man sich zum Beispiel für 130 Euro so ein Ding kaufen? Nee, egal ob das gebraucht ist oder nicht
Ich hatte schon ein paar Versuche gemacht, meine Türgegensprechanlage zu verbinden mit dem Decktelefon, ich hab auch mal sowas hier ausprobiert, das ist eigentlich ein ganz leises Gerät gewesen
So was da, nee, das sieht anders aus, das da, sowas hier, das ist eigentlich ein ganz leises Gerät gewesen, aber auch wenn es ein bisschen anders aussieht, im Prinzip ist es das
Alter, können die mal gescheite Photos machen, please? Gibt es da vielleicht ordentliche, ordentliche, ordentliche Bilder davon hier? Nee, Bilder gibt es davon nicht
Das ist eigentlich auch eine ganz gute Idee, das Gerät für Türgegensprechanlagen, ja hier erkennt man es ganz gut, das ist eigentlich ganz einfach, du klemmst hier die zwei Drähte von diesem Siedle Türgegensprechding an irgendwo hier glaube ich
Und hier machst du dein Telefon dran, das Problem an diesem Teil war nur, dass es Geräusch hat und wenn man beide Telefone an der Wand drangelassen hat, dann war das ultra leise
Das was du vorgeschlagen hast, diesen DCA-Ding, das habe ich auch gefunden und die haben sogar im offiziellen Anschlussdiagramm zwei Handy-Dinger an der Wand und dieses Teil
Ich bin, ich bin überlegt, ich bin dazu geneigt mir auf Ebay mal so ein Teil zu bestellen, das einfach auszuprobieren, ich gehe mal davon aus, die Config wird nicht sonderlich kompliziert sein, einfach anstöpseln und auf der anderen Seite ein analoges Telefonkabel
Oder? Ich gehe mal davon aus, das wird nicht sonderlich schwierig sein
Wie ist das damit? Kann man damit direkt das Gespräch annehmen am Telefon oder muss man erst irgendeine Vorwahl machen? Oder irgendeinen Code eingeben?
So, das, das musste ich euch jetzt mal erzählen, also richtig, richtig Painschamped hier gestern, deswegen habe ich gestern noch nicht gestreamt, mit Netzwerk, mit Netzwerk-Kabel in den Keller, aber es funktioniert alles, da bin ich, bin ich jetzt wirklich froh drüber, es war aber mehr Painschamped als gedacht
Ja, zumindest habe ich jetzt hier eine Netzwerkdose mit einem ganzen Port, man könnte daraus natürlich auch 200 Mbit Ports machen, wenn man denn will
Ja, ich glaube, ich bestelle mir auf Ebay mal so ein Ding und probiere das aus
Muss man einen Painschamped-Counter machen, ja
Und was mich auch verwirrt hat, was mir zum ersten Mal, zum ersten Mal so wirklich bewusst geworden ist, wusstet ihr, dass es zwei verschiedene Varianten gibt, wie man AJ45-Stecker verkabelt?
Warum gibt es da zwei Varianten? Nee, nee, nee, nicht Crossover, nee, nee, nee, das meine ich nicht
Es gibt, es gibt T568B und T568A, warum? Warum gibt es da schon wieder zwei Stück? Was denken die sich immer dabei, warum muss es für alle irgendwie zwei Sachen geben?
Tür öffnen geht auch mit einem Code, ah, nice, gut, Tür öffnen habe ich keinen, das brauche ich nicht, aber ist gut zu wissen
Also Smasin97, wenn du das nächste Mal wieder im Stream bist und ich das Ding schon angeschlossen habe, muss dich vielleicht noch mal nerven mit irgendwelchen Sachen
Das ist nicht was mit PoE zu tun, nee, PoE geht beides, es ist vollkommen egal, es ist vollkommen egal, was man verkabelt, es ist nur wichtig, dass man beide Seiten immer gleich verkabelt
Ich habe es jetzt mit B gemacht, ja, ich habe es auch mit B gemacht, aber warum ist das schon wieder, sind wir mal ernsthaft, hat jemand von euch eine Idee, warum gibt es zwei?
War vielleicht A zuerst da und man hat festgestellt, A ist unforteilhaft und es gibt jetzt B und B hat sich dann mehr etabliert, also ich habe keine Ahnung
Ach, eine Seite A und eine Seite B, dann hast du Crossover, ach so ist das gemacht, okay, also sprich, die zwei gibt es, dass man weiß, wie man Crossover-Kabel machen kann
Wurde ja schon mal Keystone Ayotte 540 in den Raum geöffnet, ja, habe ich sogar geöffnet, guck mal da
Damit habe ich das angeschlossen gestern, Kabel hier aus dem Kabelkanal raus von dem komischen Telekom Ding abgemacht, ein Keystone Ayotte 45 drauf, in den Keller runter abgeschnitten, auch ein Keystone Ayotte 45 drauf
Ja, dafür habe ich das nämlich gebraucht, weil, weil so einfach ist das natürlich nicht, weil natürlich meine Kabel etwas Paints-Champig befarbt waren, ja
Also ich hatte beispielsweise kein, also in meinem Netzwerkkabel, ich hatte kein weiß-orange, ich hatte orange und weiß zusammen gedreht, das heißt ich musste immer gucken, dass ich das schön nacheinander aufmache
Weil sonst hätte ich nicht mehr gefunden, welches weiße Kabel gehört jetzt zu welcher Farbe, also die machen einem teilweise Hardware-technisch echt das Leben schwer, anstatt sich einfach mal an sowas zu halten
Was, Türöffner brauchst du trotzdem?
Ja, ne ne ne, was ich meine ist, ich habe keine Türöffner, deswegen brauche ich das nicht
Warum war das gemeint, also ich brauche diese Funktion nicht, weil meine Tür keinen Türöffner hat
Ja, mischen geht natürlich nicht, zumal Crossover, Kabel und so, das ist ja heute mittlerweile zum größten Teil eh alles automatische Erkennung, da ist es nicht wild
Zumindest ich sage euch Leute, ich habe seit meiner Ausbildung nicht mal so viel rumgefuddelt, Netzwerkkabel, technisch wie gestern, aber es funktioniert
Ich würde euch jetzt gerne ein Foto sogar von zeigen, aber ich habe keins gemacht, aber gut, ich könnte jetzt hintergehend eins machen, aber es ist relativ unspektakulär, anstatt so eine THE-Dose ist jetzt einfach noch eine dritte Netzwerkdose
Das muss ich jetzt glaube ich nicht fotografieren, das kann man sich glaube ich vorstellen
Du hattest doch mal eine Ausbildung, ja habe ich
Ich habe meine Ausbildung vor zwei Monaten bei Binland tatsächlich noch über dein Video von der ERK Prüfung gestolpert
Ja, ich hoffe bei dir hat alles funktioniert, bei mir hat es ja nicht geklappt so richtig
Danach schon, aber erstmal ein bisschen Schock, von wegen sie sind durchgefallen
Naja gut, genug über Kabel und Sachen gelabert, damit war ich gestern beschäftigt, deswegen habe ich auch nicht gestreamt, aber ich bin froh, dass es funktioniert
Ich sage euch Leute, WLAN, endlich richtig gut im Haus, bis auf der Terrassenseite
Ich habe jetzt, ich habe jetzt einen, Alter ich habe irgendwas im Hals
Hyper Gatschi
So ich glaube jetzt reicht mal was trinken
Also, wie viel Kram macht man als Fachinformatiker eigentlich so?
Kommt auf die Firma an, also kommt auf den Betrieb an, wo man ist
In der Regel machst du als Fachinformatiker Systemintegration mehr Netzwerk- und Hardware-Sachen als ein Anwendungsentwickler
Aber die Ausbildungen nehmen sich echt nicht mehr so viel, das sieht man auch daran, dass Berufsschulen und Prüfungen zum größten Teil gleich sind
Ich hatte Glück mit meinen Prüfern, ich habe was irre Windows Server
Und die Prüfer waren richtige Linux Profis, ich wäre mit Linux zerstört von dem Fachgespräch
Na oder du hättest Pluspunkte bekommen, weil die Linux-Fans sind
Und ihr hättet keine Ahnung von Windows
Ja was ich sagen wollte, WLAN richtig gut jetzt
Ich habe im Keller über dieses neue Kabel jetzt einen UAP Lite
Dann habe ich im Erdgeschoss, das sind verschiedene Generationen, weil es die verschiedenen aufgehört
Dann habe ich einen UAP Pro im Erdgeschoss, da ist übrigens auch der Raspberry Pi dran
Und oben habe ich einen Nano HD, also ich habe jetzt drei Unify Access Points
Und ich muss sagen, jetzt, seitdem ich auf jeder Etage den Access Point habe, jetzt ist das WLAN zum ersten Mal im ganzen Haus wirklich richtig gut
Was ich nicht ganz verstehe ist, warum sich die WLAN Lampe im Wohnzimmer, also quasi im Raum neben dem ich jetzt hier sitze
Die WLAN Lampe im ersten Stock aus dem Wohnzimmer sich mit dem Access Point im Keller verbindet
Das ist mir nicht so ganz klar, aber sie macht es und sie funktioniert
Also ich kann alle Clients nachvollziehen, wie die sich verbinden
Der Raspberry Pi im Keller verbindet sich zum Access Point im Keller
Die Kamera im Keller verbindet sich zum Access Point im Keller
Alles, alles gut, alles klar, verstehe ich
Die Tasmota Steckdose verbindet sich zum Access Point im Keller, alles, alles klar
Das einzige, was absolut unbescheuert ist, warum verbindet sich die WLAN RGB Lampe, die am weitesten entfernt ist, zum Access Point im Keller
Anstatt zum Access Point im Raum neben dran oder zum Access Point im Erdgeschoss, nein, die geht zum Access Point im Keller
Obwohl sie da plus 65% Empfang hat, keine Ahnung, verstehe ich nicht, aber sie macht es und sie funktioniert
Die Logik verstehe ich eh nicht so genau, aber solange das alles funktioniert ist das kein Ding
Chat, Chat, ich weiß doch, ihr seid Massive Brain, kennt ihr ein gutes System, um Bilderkennung zu machen für analoge Anzeigen, also zum Beispiel Wasser
So was da, kennt ihr ein gutes Bilderkennungssystem, was sowas hier auslesen kann
So Nadelstände, ich rede nicht hier von Zahlen, von Nadelständen, wie gesagt, ich wollte das ja ausprobieren
Mal on stream mit meinem Stromzähler, aber für die Druckanzeige an der Heizung habe ich schon eine Kamera davor
Das würde ich jetzt gerne Bild erkennen
Also ich habe da schon eine Kamera vor, ich bräuchte jetzt irgendeine Massive trainierte AI Geschichte, die das erkennen kann
Ja, ich hatte mal was gezeigt, das geht aber über einen ESP mit Kamera, den du davor hängen musst
Und wenn ich schon eine Kamera habe, habe ich mir gedacht, ich kann den zusätzlichen ESP neben der Kamera, noch eine Kamera quasi sparen
Ja, das kann auch, ob das mit TensorFlow ist oder mit was auch immer ist mir egal
Ich will aber, dass das schon vortrainiert ist und am besten irgendeinen Web Server dabei hat, wo ich einfach nur meine Bilder hinschicken muss
Und der gibt mir als Jason zurück, keine Ahnung, 0,5, das wäre mir ehrlich gesagt am liebsten
Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, sowas gibt es wahrscheinlich nicht fertig, aber das wäre äußerst praktisch
Dann könnte ich nämlich in mein Home Assistant einfach einbinden auf der Startseite, Wasserdruck in der Heizung
Ohne, dass ich auf die Kamera gucken muss
Hätte ja sein können, dass einer von euch eine Ahnung hat, wie gesagt, ja das kenne ich, das kenne ich, das ist auch das, was ich hier gerade gezeigt habe
Ich will es ja nicht mit dem ESP32 machen, da müsste ja eine Kamera neben der Kamera hängen, das ist ja auch doof
Okay, dann würde ich sagen, gucken wir mal ein paar Bits
Ja, denkt sich die Lampe echt, also was auch immer, es ist komplett bescheuert, dass sich die Lampe aus dem ersten Stock mit dem Access Point im Keller verbindet
Aber meinetwegen
Anyline, was ist denn Anyline, kenne ich nicht
Things that shouldn't exist, zeig mal her
Internet Explorer for Unix, ja gut
Das habe ich schon mal gesehen, da habe ich glaube ich sogar mal überlegt, ob ich ein Video zu machen sollte
Oh, hier, big brain time, chat, ups, will es copypasten
Genau, genau sowas
Genau sowas will ich machen
Blablabla, ja hier hat das eine Kamera oben drüber
Ja, das brauche ich alles nicht, ich habe ja schon ein Kamerabild
Ich habe ja schon ein Kamerabild, das brauche ich alles nicht
OpenCV Part
Aha, wow
Monka
Was zum
To make everything work well isn't that easy, ja das habe ich mir schon gedacht
Scripts and source code, watermeter code
Ok, das wurde ewig nicht aktualisiert
Oh, ach du scheiße quickmuffs
Ne, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf, da brauche ich irgendwas fertiges, das mache ich nicht selbst
Da bin ich ein halbes Jahr beschäftigt
Quickmuffs hier
Alles klar, easy
Ich glaube so kompliziert ist das gar nicht
Ah, die Hullpoints, alles klar
Ich glaube das gebe ich mir nicht
Zeit für Wasserzähler as a service, sehr gute Idee
Was ist denn das, things that shouldn't exist
21 Minuten
What the fuck
E, es ist allen Ernstes Internet Explorer
Es ist Internet Explorer
Und w, warum
Warum
Das ist doch nicht das Zeug gesehen, aber eigentlich eine gute Idee das mal auszuprobieren
So mal ein bisschen Zeug zeigen was Microsoft getrieben hat vor 30 Jahren
Naja
So, also
Gucken wir kurz chat
Und gucken wir ein paar Witz
Echt nicht?
Das Problem
Also ich habe relativ viele Kabel gemacht in der Ausbildung
Gute, ich habe auch beim Provider gearbeitet, wir waren öfters im Rechenzentrum, also da hat man ab und zu mal Kabel gemacht
Aber ich war da auch kein großer Fan von
Was ist deine Meinung zu GitHub Copilot
Spielerei
Ich weiß es gibt da die Verschwörungstheorie
Was heißt Verschwörungstheorie
Die Vermutung
Microsoft möchte alle Programmierer arbeitslos machen, indem sie sich quasi selbst wegtrainieren
Also die Leute programmieren, checken es bei GitHub ein, GitHub trainiert Copilot, sodass man irgendwann keine Programmierer mehr braucht
Habe ich so meine Zweifel
Ob das der Fall sein wird
Ich habe nie den Ausfall produziert im großen Stil
Die größten Ausfall den ich mal produziert habe ist durch einen Wackelkontakt von einem Kabel zum ESX
Aber da konnte ich nichts für
Und meint, das war eigentlich lustig
Mein jetziger Chef
War damals zuständig für ESXe
Und hat noch zu mir gesagt, mach mal die und die Kabel raus
Habe ich gemacht, also in der Ausbildung noch
Habe ich gemacht und Kabel drum herum oder sonst wir hatten irgendwie Wackelkontakt und deswegen hat der ESX Cluster gemeint
Die fliegen jetzt mal aus dem Cluster raus und dann waren dann irgendwie 40 VMs nicht mehr erreichbar
Das war der größte Ausfall den ich je produziert habe, aber da konnte ich nichts für
Loop stecken
Da sollte ja normalerweise nichts passieren
Ich habe schon das Gegenteil erlebt
Dass Switches Sachen im Kreis stecken, das habe ich schon mit auch teurer Cisco Switches
Aber normalerweise sollte es ja nicht passieren
Wir hatten übrigens auch mal lustigerweise das Problem
Dass gerade das, was diesen Loop verhindern soll, das ist ja normalerweise so
Wenn du Switche an Switche an Switche an Switche steckst
Und die miteinander verkabelt, dann gibt es sowas, das nennt sich Spanning Tree, das guckt, dass du keine Schleifen baust
So, und wenn du ein relativ großes Layer 2 Netz hast
Dann kann das passieren, dass Spanning Tree, also du stöpselst was
Und Spanning Tree baut sich neu auf, dass das Minuten braucht
Das hatten wir auch mal das Problem
Dann ging das Netzwerk quasi irgendwie 3 Minuten nicht, weil Spanning Tree erst mal aufbauen musste
Ja, alles schon mal
Ja, das kenne ich, das kenne ich, das habe ich doch schon im Stream gezeigt
Das kenne ich, die Sache ist die
Ich will ja kein ESP davor hängen
Ich habe ja schon ein Bild von der Kamera da unten
Das heißt, ich will jetzt nicht die Kamera und dann noch ein ESP daneben hängen
Kann man das eigentlich, kann man das Kamerabild eigentlich per RTSP abgreifen?
Oder MJPEG oder so, kann man hier von irgendwie das Bild abgreifen?
Weil das wäre auch eine Option
Naja, wie auch immer
Ich würde sagen, wir fangen mal an, wir gucken jetzt ein paar Witz
Das Ding machen wir dazu
Leider gibt es heute irgendwie auf YouTube nur Mist
Ich habe ein bisschen, ich habe ein bisschen
Was ist das denn?
Hier
Alles klar
Ähm, weißt du eigentlich, warum es hier Code by GitHub gibt?
Äh, wie jetzt?
Warum soll es das nicht geben?
Also was verwirrt dich daran, dass es z.B. Studio Code by GitHub gibt?
Kennt jemand eine gute Möglichkeit, diese Twitch-Wordsperre zu umgehen?
Nee, habe ich mich ja nie mit beschäftigt
Äh?
Da komme ich jetzt nicht mit zu Big-Brainer-Chat für mich schon
Fehlen noch ein paar Prime-Subs, dass mein IQ erweitert wird, wenn ich das verstehe
So, also es gibt, es gibt keine gescheiten Videos, die mir empfohlen wurden, also kaum, kaum
Deswegen ist das erste, was wir uns jetzt angucken müssen, nein das da nicht
Ähm, wir lassen uns, den habe ich übrigens noch nicht geguckt
Den können wir uns heute mal zusammen, hat wahrscheinlich, ich meine es haben 2,3 Millionen Leute geguckt
Ihr habt den Battlefield-Shortfilm sicherlich schon gesehen, ne?
Was bei GitHub, Punkt drücken?
Was zum, was wollt ihr von mir, Punkt?
Excellent
So, ich gehe mal zu mir in
Und jetzt?
Soll ich, soll ich auschecken, Punkt
Login, nee kann ich jetzt nicht machen
Ok, das ist mir, das ist mir zu high IQ, komme ich gerade nicht mit
Jebaited
You got jebaited
GitHub kann Repos in Online-VS-Code eröffnen
Ach so, Alter
Ihr müsst sowas schon schreiben, das muss also normalen Sterblicher verstehen
Ach so, ja jetzt
Ok, jetzt habe ich es gecheckt, äh, warum?
Ja gut, was sich GitHub dabei gedacht hat, weiß ich nicht, aber
Das ist von der gleichen Firma, also GitHub gehört zu Microsoft, Visual Studio Code gehört zu Microsoft
Dass die versuchen da so eine Online
Äh, Bearbeitungsgeschichte aufzubauen, weil spätestens seit GitHub
Wie hieß das, GitHub, GitHub Spaces oder so?
Äh, klar, dass die was in der Richtung probieren, das wundert mich jetzt nicht
Dass man, dass man immer mehr Edit-Möglichkeiten auf GitHub bekommt
Gut, also, was schauen wir uns jetzt an?
Das muss ich mir gar nicht angucken, wenn das das Kokona Haus
Also, also, prediction, prediction
Er will 10 Gigabit in sein Haus einbauen
Der nimmt jetzt gleich eine Schere und schneidet ein Loch in die Wand
Oder eine Säge und schneidet ein Loch in die Wand
Das ist 100% richtiges Kokona Haus
Pass mal auf, pass mal auf, ich wette mit euch
Ja, ja, ok, ok
Mal gucken, ob ich richtig liege
Hier, mach Gigabit-Fiber
Haha, ich wusste
Hell yeah
Die Amis wieder, Alter
Die Amis wieder, einfach mal mit der Säge ein Loch in die Wand schneiden
Viel Spaß, ja, ja, kein Problem
Mach das mal in einem ordentlichen Haus hier
Wobei, der hat zumindest die Außenwände
Die Außenwände scheinen zumindest immer noch Stein zu sein bei dem
Ja, dann ist es kein Problem neue Dosen in die Wand zu machen, wenn du einfach nur eine Säge brauchst
Ja
Nein, kann ich nicht, weil mein Home ist aus Stein
Doch, doch, es ist im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes hart
Gut, das muss man sich ja nicht angucken, das ist Kokona-Style-Umbau
Ja, super, einfach mal Löcher in die Wand schneiden, so mag ich das
Ok, da lassen wir uns jetzt ein bisschen Level Cap chibaden
Wir lassen uns ein bisschen Level Cap chibaden
Also, stiegs los
Wer hätte das gedacht, dass der Playtest Datamined wird, da hätte man ja gar nicht mitrechnen können
Ich mein, Datamined ist eh nur ein fancy Word von, man extrahiert Strings und Sachen aus den gepackten Dateien
Also Datamined hört sich immer so wahnsinnig, so wahnsinnig big brain an
Ah, ist das Dings hier, ist das der Kurzfilm? Die kommen uns wirklich mal an, sieht nice aus
Das ist doch der Typ aus Battlefield 4
Das ist doch der Typ aus Battlefield 4?
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern? Warte mal
Weg 17 jetzt, für Altersfreigaben, Videos an, das ist der 100-Bruder-Dude aus Battlefield 4
Du musst angemeldet sein, um es zu benutzen, ja denkst du, denkst du, muss ich nicht
Der alte angemeldet sein Hack funktioniert immer noch, einfach auf embedded umschalten, easy
Das ist der Typ aus dem Auto am Anfang, ja und wisst ihr was ich cool finde? Ich hab zum Release irgendwann, in irgendeinem, wo wir uns die Gameplay-Trailer zusammen angeguckt haben
Hab ich doch noch gesagt, ey der eine Typ, ich weiß nicht, der eine Soldat, der Typ sieht aus wie der aus dem Battlefield-Singleplayer
Und wahrscheinlich hat man das da schon gesehen
Egal, wir lassen uns jetzt weiter von Levelcapped schieben
Lohnt sich der Film, lohnt sich der Kurzfilm überhaupt anzugucken?
Also ich muss sagen, ich fand die Overwatch-Kurzfilme immer nice
Was ich halt cool fand, dass die Overwatch-Kurzfilme so bisschen, wie sagt man so, leichtherzig sagt man das auf Deutsch auch so
Jetzt nicht so ernst waren
Übrigens, das ist auch so ein Ding, da muss ich noch mal kurz was zu sagen
Als erstes hieß es, der Battlefield-Playtest wäre zwei bis drei Monate alt
So, danach hat der Ober-Battlefield-Leaker, wie hieß er, Tom Henderson, Bild-Age
Der hat irgendwas geschrieben
Ja, also er hat erst geschrieben, das Playtest-Bild ist drei bis vier Monate alt
Und dann hat er gesagt, Info is wrong, Bild ist actually from 29. Juli
Die Sache ist halt die, dass das überhaupt nichts miteinander zu tun hat
Ich mein, das hier ist, wo irgendwie mal ein Bild-Job gelaufen ist und hat den Kram kompiliert
Ich mein, wir kennen ihre Pipeler nicht, wir kennen ihre Build-Scripts oder sonst was nichts
Kennen das nicht, also keine Ahnung, ob der das Datum vom letzten Commit nimmt, ob das hardcoded ist
Oder ob der einfach das aktuelle Datum vom Build-Vorgang nimmt
Aber nur, weil das Bild am 29. Juli passiert ist, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass das auch vom 29. Juli ist
Der Source-Code ist garantiert von diesem Test, der ist Monate alt, wenn drei bis vier Monate überhaupt ausreichen
Es ist auch eindeutig irgendein Test-Bild, das siehst du, die Beleuchtung ist überhaupt nicht richtig in dem Game drinnen
Die Sachen sind teilweise sehr hakelig, du siehst noch irgendwie Umrisse an Stellen, wo du keine sehen sollst
Also BobartSH, danke schön für den Prime-Sub
Also das ist auf jeden Fall kein Bild von einem Battlefield, was in zwei Monaten rauskommt
Was wir da gesehen haben, ja, also auch nicht hier vom 29. Juli
Also, ich persönlich gehe davon aus, also so wie ich das machen würde, ist
Okay, wir wollen einen Playtest machen, das heißt es gibt eh schon mal zwei grundsätzliche Komponenten
Du hast einmal den Client für das Game, der ist am 29. Juli kompiliert worden
Und du hast die Server-Seite, die Server-Seite wird natürlich deutlich neuer sein als die Client-Seite
In dem Fall
An der Server-Seite werden die permanent rumbasteln
So, also wie ich das machen würde, ist, ich weiß, okay, wir wollen einen Playtest machen oder eine Beta machen oder was auch immer
Das heißt, ich nehme einen Stand, der aktuell halbwegs funktioniert
Also sprich, ich guck mir einfach so mal die letzten Tage durch, welcher Stand, welchen Stand hatten wir denn da
Der am ehesten irgendwie spielbar ist oder den man am ehesten in irgendwas Spielbares umbauen kann
Dann mache ich mir einen eigenen Branch auf, was weiß ich, Playtest
Und dann picke ich da oder fixe ich da nur die Sachen drin, die wirklich essentiell sind für diesen Playtest
So, und vielleicht war das letzte Commit da drin am 29. Juli
So, und dann drückt irgendwann einer
Ein paar Tage oder paar Wochen, ja, ja, ist gut für Nuss, bevor der Playtest anfängt
Auf den Jetzt Kompilieren-Button, dann muss das Ganze noch verifiziert werden, in Origin eingecheckt werden und sonst was
Und der Stand unten drunter, nur, was ich sagen will, nur weil da steht, der Bild ist vom 29.
Das heißt noch lange nicht, dass der Source-Code-Stand vom 29. ist, weil das ist er garantiert nicht
Wahrscheinlich ist er sogar noch älter, weil die sich darauf vorbereitet haben, den Playtest zu machen
Und das genommen haben, was eben der spielbarste Stand ist, den sie haben und den dann so weit hingedreht, dass es spielbar ist
Max erwähnt sein Stream viel zu wenig in Videos, ja, müsste öfters Sellout machen, das stimmt, richtig
Ja, also ich gehe davon aus, dass hier stimmt, vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen älter, 3-4 Monate erscheint sind
Also ich gehe davon aus, er hat mit beiden Sachen recht, der eigentliche Code, also die Basis dürfte, mit ein paar Comments als Ausnahme
Dürfte 3-4 Monate alt sein, aber das Bild mag vom 29. sein, so, weiter geht's
Ja, ich werde oftmals witzigerweise YouTube Abonnenten empfohlen auf Twitch, ich weiß nicht, wie das Google und Bezos untereinander so ausmachen, keine Ahnung
Aha, aha, das würde tatsächlich Sinn ergeben zu dem, was die auch in dieser FAQ Session gesagt haben
Also Hazard Zone haben sie angekündigt mit High Stakes Squadplay und sie haben in der FAQ Session auch öfter sowas in der Richtung erzählt
Sie wollten aber nicht im Detail darauf eingehen, weil sie haben gesagt, das wird zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt vorgestellt
Sie haben dann quasi die Sache nochmal wiederholt, ja, das ist quasi High Intense Blablabla Squadplay, aber heute geht's um All-Out Warfare und Battlefield 2042, der Corespielmodus
Das ergibt Sinn, weil wir haben die, Leute, ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen
Also ich war ja auf zwei Events, wo es danach jeweils ungefähr eine Stunde lang noch Frage und Antwort mit Dice gab, und ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen
Ratet mal, oder doch, ihr könnt's euch vorstellen, ratet mal, was mindestens 50% der Fragen waren, mindestens 50%
Also, wenn nicht sogar 60-70%
Skill-Based Matchmaking, da, das wurde auch ab und zu gefragt, aber nicht so oft
Battle Royale, korrekt
Mindestens 50% der Fragen, wie sieht's mit Battle Royale aus?
Und sie haben halt immer wieder betont, sie sagen nichts dazu, sie sagen nichts dazu, bis er mega pissed war irgendwann
Weil er nur noch nach Battle Royale gefragt wird und hat gesagt, zum Release wird Battlefield kein Battle Royale enthalten
Und das ergibt Sinn, auf der einen Seite schreiben sie, also diese Meldung ergibt Sinn
Auf der einen Seite hatten sie so ganz groß was erzählt von High-Stakes-Squad-Gameplay und auf der anderen Seite kein Battle Royale
Das heißt, dass so eine Mischung aus Escape vom Tarkov und Hunt Showdown kommt in Hazard Zone, das kann ich mir vorstellen
Und ich hab ja im Vorfeld gesagt, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie quasi diese Battle Royale-Geschichte schleifen lassen, nachdem Warzone so gut angekommen ist
Aber ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, ich hab immer noch was im Hals, das ist heute echt der Wahnsinn
Ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass sie versuchen einen eigenen Spin diesem ganzen Battle Royale Zeug zu geben
Dankeschön, 100 Millionen Euro, poggers, jetzt bin ich reich, Massive, danke Wolle, 604
Und ich glaube, das ist der eigene Spin, da drauf
Es ist kein richtig klassischer Battle Royale, aber es ist ein bisschen per Battle Royale das Battlefield
Vielleicht, ja
Ich bin gespannt, ich bin echt gespannt
Sie versuchen ja auf mehreren Gleisen zu fahren, sie versuchen die klassische Battlefield Experience mit All-Out-Warfare zu machen
Das hier, könnte ich mir vorstellen, ist so ein bisschen für die Streaming- und eSport- und Competitive-Fraktion
Weil normales Battlefield zuzugucken auf Twitch ist jetzt nicht so spannend
Also Battle Royale zuzugucken, deswegen ist das ja auch so erfolgreich geworden, ist schon spannender als normales Battlefield
Und ja, dann gibt es im Portal noch was für die Bastler
Was, aber die haben doch schon Apex als Battle Royale, dann würden die sich nicht selber Konkurrenz machen
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob Battlefield und Apex, obwohl es ein Battle Royale, ich meine, die haben auch Firestorm gemacht
Darf man nicht vergessen, ob sich das so überschneidet
Also ich sehe erstens den Grund nicht, warum man nicht beide spielen soll
Und ich sehe die Überschneidung gar nicht so großartig
Apex ist eher das Quake der Battle Royales
Wohingegen Battlefield eindeutig eher gegen Warzone competitive-mäßig antritt
Also ich sehe da jetzt zwar natürlich Überschneidung und es werden sicherlich auch die gleichen Leute beide spielen
Aber wenn ich sagen würde, ok, wenn du so die zwei Gruppen hast, du hast die Apex-Gruppe
Also auf Huge-Paint-Skills
Also du hast hier so die Apex-Gruppe und du hast hier so die Battlefield-Gruppe
Dann würde ich sagen, das überschneidet sich vielleicht so
Aber die hier bleiben exklusiv Apex, die hier bleiben exklusiv Battlefield
Und du hast in der Mitte bestimmt ein paar, wo das dann auch nacheinander abwandern werden
Aber ich glaube so viel ist das gar nicht
So, Apex
Ja, Riko, das stimmt
Ich gehe davon aus, dass die können das Streaming im Jahr 2021 einfach nicht links liegen lassen
Das ist so
Die müssen erstens gucken, dass das Spiel in irgendeiner Art und Weise interessant ist für Streamer
Also du lässt einfach so extrem, mega viel Potenzial liegen, wenn du heute nicht irgendwie versuchst
Also bei so großen Games
Ja, ich rede jetzt nicht von irgendwie zwei Mann in die Steam spielen oder so
Weil wenn so große Games nicht versuchen, in irgendeiner Art und Weise Streaming anzusprechen
Das ist einfach extrem viel verschenktes Potenzial heutzutage
Und natürlich der nächste Punkt ist, wenn sich Streamer dafür interessieren
Da musst du gucken, dass sie das auch halbwegs spielen können
Gerade bei großen Streamern, und das muss ja nicht immer so groß sein wie Montana Black
Das kann ja auch, nehm mal den Lost
Der hat nicht so viele Zuschauer, der spielt aber relativ viel Battlefield oder PUBG und Battle Royale Sachen
Selbst dort und selbst bei mir ist es ja schon abfuck gewesen
Ich weiß noch, wir haben mal Battlefield 3 gespielt vor einer Weile
Sogar ich hatte Streamsniper, unglaublich
In Battlefield 3 im Jahr 2021
Ich hatte irgendwie 250 zu, ich hatte Streamsniper
Das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen
Ein 10 Jahre altes Spiel auf Twitch, wo kaum einer zu, ich hatte Streamsniper
Wahnsinn, echt krasses Zeug ja
Und da will ich gar nicht wissen wie das bei denen ist
Das heißt der nächste Punkt ist, du musst tatsächlich gucken, dass du es nicht nur interessant machst für Streamer
Sondern eben auch gut spielbar machst für Streamer
Ja
Definitiv
Wir gucken uns gleich mal an
Wir gucken uns gleich mal an, ich hab's noch nicht gesehen
Spoiler
Wo ist Hanna?
Leute, nein nicht spoilern
Ist Hanna auch wieder dabei?
Battlefield 4 war der einzige Singleplayer, wo ich sowas wie Motion sickness bekommen habe
Weil da so viel Blur und Gewackel war
Dass ich es nicht wirklich genießen konnte beim Spielen
Ich hab es glaube ich auch nie durchgespielt
Und Hanna war nervig
Wobei Hanna stirbt doch am Ende oder?
Von Battlefield 4, nee dann ist sie da wahrscheinlich nicht dabei
Mal gucken, mal gucken
Woge ist da ja eh nicht so weit her
Warum sollten sie das denn machen?
Warum sollten sie irgendjemand vom Final Game banen?
Wieso, die wollen noch alle Geld
Übrigens, dieses Foto hier, das ist mega Gbait
Was er hier gemacht hat ist, es sieht aus, auf dem Thumbnail, als wäre das aus dem Playtest Gameplay
Dabei ist das aus dem allerersten Ankündigungstrailer mit ein bisschen Sättigungseffekte in Photoshop
Also er hat quasi es geschafft, den Anschein zu erwecken
Es wäre leaked Gameplay, dabei ist es einfach nur leicht farbveränderter Trailer
Richtig massiv
Der wollte sich aber nicht in die Brennnesseln setzen und Bilder rein machen
Hab ich ja auch nicht gemacht
Hab ich ja auch nicht gemacht, also ich hab mir auch gedacht, ey ich lass es lieber mal sein
Ja, da bin ich ja eh gespannt
Replaces? Replaces? Warum gibt es nicht einfach beides?
Wo ist das Problem? Wo ist das Problem an mehr als einer Map?
Schafft es Ravensoft nicht zu handeln mehr als eine Map oder was?
Ich mein, die tun sich ja schon schwer mit einer Map
Ja, da bin ich übrigens auch mal gespannt
Ich mein, Call of Duty ist in zwei Monaten oder so ja auch raus
Und du hast noch nichts gehört und nichts gesehen
Außer ein paar Mini-Teaser-Leaked-Dinger
Also ich glaube, das wäre ein Fehler Verdans komplett zu ersetzen durch eine World War II Map
Weil es gibt viele Leute, die haben einfach keinen Bock auf World War II
Die wollen Warzone nicht ein Jahr auf World War II Maps spielen
Die müssen beides rein machen
Ubah!
Ich verstehe bis heute nicht, was die geritten hat, da jetzt wieder auf World War II zu machen
Vielleicht ist die Idee aber gar nicht so schlecht, jetzt wo Battlefield am Start ist
Mit Modern Warfare, dass sie sich vielleicht nicht immer gegenseitig nachrennen
Sondern was anderes haben als Kontrast
Vielleicht ist es gar nicht so blöd
Rico, man weiß es noch nicht, das ganze heißt Vanguard anscheinend ein Spiel im Zweiten Weltkrieg
Aber man hat weder was gesehen noch groß was gehört bisher von
Sehr untypisch
Das glaubst du doch selbst nicht, dass ich da was tun werde
Ravensoft kann da überhaupt nichts fixen
Ravensoft dürfte eines der unfähigsten Läden überhaupt sein
Aber das juckt die nicht, der Scheiß verkauft sich anscheinend immer noch gut
Und solange sich das gut verkauft, hooker
Es ist ein offizieller Trailer für ihr nächstes Portable PC, das Stream Deck
Es macht ein paar tolle Worte, so wie es die stärkste Handheld-Gaming in der Welt ist
Das ist ja auch nicht schwer
Die stärkste Handheld-Gaming in der Welt, was gibt es denn da als Konkurrenz?
Der DS und die Switch
Ich meine es ist nicht großartig kompliziert mehr Power zu haben als die Switch
Und wobei die Switch gar nicht mal schlecht ist
Es ist ein offizieller Trailer für ihr nächstes Portable PC, das Stream Deck
Es macht ein paar tolle Worte, so wie es die stärkste Handheld-Gaming in der Welt ist
Das ist ja auch nicht schwer
Die stärkste Handheld-Gaming in der Welt, was gibt es denn da als Konkurrenz?
Der DS und die Switch
Es ist ein offizieller Trailer für ihr nächstes Portable PC, das Stream Deck
Es macht ein paar tolle Worte, so wie es die stärkste Handheld-Gaming in der Welt ist
Die reviewerinnen und reviewerinnen haben vor einiger Zeit mit den Vor- und Vorbereitungsmodellen der Steam Deck
an der Valve HQ und ihre Erfahrung war sehr positiv
Die meisten haben eine sehr gute Performance in Doom Eternal und anderen Spielen
an der native Resolution des Devils
Die Steam Deck ist aktuell zur Verfügung als Reservation-Order auf Steam
und beginnt im Dezember zu erwerben
Nintendo hat eine permanente Abmeldung gegen den Rom-Univers erhalten
Nintendo hat vorhin das Rom-Universum bezahlt und wurde 2,1 Mio. Dollar bezahlt.
Ja und die haben doch gesagt, sie bezahlen es nicht, oder?
Willst du dir eins holen? Keine Ahnung, da habe ich mir noch nicht überlegt.
...ROMs oder playable-Disc-Images von Nintendo-Games.
Während ROMs nicht technisch illegal sind,
distribuieren sie sie und machen Geld aus dieser Distribution.
An einem Punkt wurde das Rom-Universum ca. 30.000 Dollar pro Jahr
von unbedeuteten Accounts, die die Subscriber mitverkaufen.
Moment, 30.000 Euro im Jahr? Das ist ja nix!
Da verdienst du ja als McDonalds-Mitarbeiter mehr.
Und dafür musst du nicht eine Webseite betreiben
und von Nintendo bis ans Ende der Welt verklagt werden.
Das ist ja nix!
30.000 Euro ist ja nix!
...faster Downloads and no limits on how many ROMs that they could download.
The site's owner seemed intent on continuing his operations
despite the initial court loss.
This injunction prohibits him from copying, distributing, selling
or playing unauthorized copies of Nintendo-Games.
The judge on the case ordered ROM-Universum to destroy
all of the pirated Nintendo-Games that they hosted as well.
The social media hype...
Wie stellt sich das der Richter vor?
Wie soll man denn ROMs destroyen?
Sind das wieder irgendwelche Richter, die keine Ahnung haben,
um was es da eigentlich geht?
Wie destroyt man bitteschön ROMs?
In Papierkorb schieben, oder wie?
Saga, das ist Abandon's Reveal,
bleibt nur noch auf.
Das Spiel ist ein nächstes PS5-Exklusiv-Titel
und ist umgekehrt von Konspiration-Theorien,
die behaupten, es sei secretly Hideo Kojima's nächstes Titel.
Die Entwickler haben die Flames
durch eine Teaser-Image mit einem Charakter mit einem Eye-Patch, wie Big Boss,
aka Snake, aus den Metal Gear Games.
Sie haben auch endlich eine App für Abandon geöffnet,
die als spielbare Demo-Experienzen verwendet werden soll.
Und leider sind die Dinge zu einem hohen Start.
Nach dem Download der App finden die Spieler einen einzigen...
Also, eins kann Kojima ja wirklich.
Und das ist so diese, diese schnippchen, häppchenweise
Werbung und Hype aufbauen für seine Games im Vorfeld.
Also das kann der echt wie kein anderer.
PC-Hardware-Maker GIGABYTE hat endlich zu Claims
dass zwei ihrer Power Supply Modelle Zeitbomben sind.
Hardware-Review-Outlet Gamers Nexus
hat ein Exposé auf GIGABYTE's P850GM und GP750GM Power Supplies gemacht.
Sie fanden, dass beide Modelle eine sehr hohe Fehlerrate hatten,
die katastrophal war, also es könnte explodieren und dein PC mit dem explodieren.
Gamers Nexus testete 10 Modelle und 50% explodierte.
GIGABYTE...
Haben die keinerlei Qualitätskontrolle, oder was?
... klaims, das Problem ist, dass die Type der Testung durchgeführt wird, um den Fall zu verhindern.
Sie sagen, in der echten Welt hat niemand die Power Supply-Kapazität komplett zerstört.
Es ist scheißegal, ob das in der echten Welt jemand macht.
Das hat die Specks, die draufstehen, auszuhalten, plus noch ein bisschen Toleranz nach oben.
Dummes Marketing-Geschwätze da.
... für eine längere Zeit.
However, Gamers Nexus also hatte eine Power Supply-Unit-Fail unter 60% Test-Load.
GIGABYTE adjustierte die Power Supply-Unit-Failure-Protektion-Threshold
und antwortete jemandem, der sich um den Fehler interessiert, um den Kunden-Support zu kontaktieren.
Aber es war ein Problem.
GIGABYTE wurde vorhin mit einem Ransomware-Attack getroffen,
das ihre Kunden-Support-Server off-line getroffen hat.
Als sie das geschrieben haben, waren ihre Serven off-line für über eine Woche
und ihre Kunden-Support-Staff hatten Probleme...
Haben sie sich selbst gehackt, dass sie nicht so viel Support anfragen kriegen?
RMAs, Returns und Support-Tickets.
Also, das Refund- oder Replacement-Prozess könnte viel länger dauern, als erwartet.
Das ist ein Zufall, dass ihre Kunden-Support-Site zu Beginn ist.
Und das endet mit diesem Wochenende-Gaming.
Wie immer, Leute, ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Das muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
Wie Netzteile explodieren.
Exploding Power Supplies.
Auf geht's.
Wow.
Das ist wirklich schlecht.
This is called a catastrophic failure.
So is this.
And this.
Das ist schlecht.
Das ist ganz schlecht.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich hatte noch nie bis auf eins
ein Power Supply, was kaputtgegangen ist.
Ich hatte mal ein ganz billiges LC-Power vor Jahren.
Das ist ein billiges China-Ding.
GP-P750GM
or closely related GP-P850GM.
One of these catastrophically failed while under only 60% load.
And out of the ten or so units that we bought from Newegg
or acquired from viewers, we had...
Newegg ist auch so eine richtige Kokona-Shop-Seite, ne?
Newegg kaufen die ganzen Amis immer ihre Hardware.
Several other catastrophic failures.
During the course of testing, we blew three fuses
from our Power Supply load tester
and we toasted a Gigabyte RTX 3080
that was attached to one of the Power Supplies.
Okay.
A shocking 50% of these failed in an explosive capacity
while we were testing them.
That's some pretty good odds for...
Also, Leute, sollen wir das ganz gucken?
Ich mein, 30 Minuten ist relativ lang.
Ansonsten würde ich mal vorskippen, wo's kaputtgeht.
Ja, da geht's kaputt.
Suspicion got some test data to back it all up.
Wo geht's kaputt?
Das wird eigentlich nur explodierende Netzteile sehen.
Testing equipment...
Testing units?
...we then tested a viewer-provided 750 in March and a viewer-provided 850 with a mild spark and then a small puff of smoke.
This one shared the same failure location as our first failed...
Hä? Ist da was passiert? Ich hab jetzt nichts gesehen.
...the next unit we tested failed while attempting to locate the exact OPV trigger point.
This time the right APFC FET failed with a mild...
Ah, da, da, da. Habt ihr's gesehen?
...spark and then a small puff of smoke.
This one shared the same failure location as our first failed 850 watt unit.
So now we'd had...
...at this point.
Okay, das ist wirklich...
...nicht gut.
Wann kommt nächstes Azubi-Video?
Als nächstes muss ich erstmal Stellenanzeigen-Video machen.
Dann muss ich noch ein Hetzner Sellout-Video machen.
Das könnte ich eventuell kombinieren mit...
...der Azubi-Story über die illegal gehosteten Sachen bei uns im Rechenzentrum.
We needed to build a system that we were okay with...
...losing any of the parts in it...
...44800 Mhz memory running at 3600...
Oh, jetzt kommt richtig MonkaS-Smoke.
We can't be 100% certain what the failure is.
But we have some pretty good ideas at this point.
So, our belief is that...
...a protection circuit needs improvement.
Do not buy.
Sehr gute Idee. Do not buy, Leute.
Da wäre ich jetzt auch drauf gekommen.
Hey Snoop.
You're the best thing since sliced bread.
Get it? Cause you're a loaf.
Ist das schlecht?
Das ist Standard-Katzenblick.
Alter, lass mich in Ruhe gehen, wenn ich auf den Sack.
14 Monate. Danke schön für den Sub.
Massive. Huge Hyper-Subscription hier.
Mein neuer Smart Home Server-Einrichtung.
Das wurde mir vorhin vorgeschlagen. Ich weiß nicht warum.
Ich hab von ihm noch nie was geguckt.
Die Bewertungen sind wahrscheinlich richtig gut.
Wisst ihr, was das sein wird?
Das sind die üblichen Leute, die alles, was irgendjemand zu Hause baut, negativ bewerten.
Du hast so Leute.
Das sind die gleichen Leute, die danach ins Mikro-Controller-Forum gehen...
...und Neulinge anflamen, dass sie zu dumm sind...
...und sich hier nie wieder blicken lassen sollen.
24 Monate. Danke schön für den Sub.
Das Dubai-Video ist echt gut.
Das geht auch nur 12 Minuten.
Was machen eigentlich unsere ganzen Influencers in Dubai?
Ich hab gehört, die ziehen jetzt wieder zurück.
We hear the word Dubai. Most of us picture towering skyscrapers.
Immense wealth.
Also an Dubai denk ich an zwei Sachen.
Was? Wann gehst du?
Oder wann ich aufgeh? Keine Ahnung. Dauert noch ein bisschen.
Also bei Dubai denk ich an zwei Sachen.
An komische Influencer, die erzählen, dass Dubai das geilste überhaupt ist...
...und an diese komische Insel, die sie ins Meer gebaut haben.
Ich weiß nicht wie das heißt.
Dubai...
Wie heißt denn dieses Ding?
Maps.
Das hier.
Pepe... ah nee, Palm.
Das mein ich.
Die einfach hier künstliche Insel ins Meer.
Die hören ja gar nicht auf. Das werden ja immer mehr.
Das hört ja gar nicht auf.
The world ist jetzt hier am Start.
Was auch immer the world ist.
Ah, the world.
France, Spain, Portugal, Switzerland.
Wo ist Germany? Gibt's nicht?
Das müsste ja hier so irgendwie sein, oder?
Gibt's nicht.
France ist da.
Das sind die Schweden?
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung was das sein soll.
Das heißt, jede Insel ist ein Land, oder wie?
Congo.
Tja, die wollen es echt wissen.
Aber Germany gibt's nicht.
Wahrscheinlich irgendwie eins von diesen Inseln, was hier nicht belegt ist.
Naja, so, kommen wir mal. Dubai.
Also das ist das erste zwei Sachen, wo ich an Dubai-Dubai dran denke.
Komische deutsche Influencer, die in Dubai am Start sind und diese Insel im Meer.
Ja, das mein ich, genau.
Aha.
War nicht, war nicht Zebra Tower hier von irgendwie inspiriert?
Nee, Zebra Tower in Battlefield 3 war in Teheran, oder?
Nicht in Dubai.
Die Battlefield 3 Map.
Oh, für Comrades.
Doch nicht.
Oh, das sind Geschichte-Lessons.
Was kann schon schiefgehen?
Big Brain Time.
Was genau hat das jetzt mit Dubai zu tun?
Ich bin noch nicht so ganz dahinter gekommen.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das hier ist der Bahnsteig und dahinter geht's nicht mehr weiter, oder was?
Das ist dann...
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen klein.
Da ist was dran, ja.
Ah, okay, das ist der Aufhänger gewesen.
Ich glaube, der Typ wird kein Dubai-Influencer mehr.
Ich habe gehört, ich habe gehört sagen, dass ein Zimmer dort gar nicht so teuer ist, weil kaum jemand hin will.
Das muss wohl am Anfang so ein riesen Magnet gewesen sein an Besucher und alles und mittlerweile ist das wohl zum größten Teil total leer.
Machst du mal lauter? Ich dachte, das ist eigentlich okay. Ich kann hier ein bisschen lauter machen, da müssen wir aber hier runter drehen, sonst übersteuert's.
Moment.
Moment, das Ding hat keine Kanalisation?
Sehe ich das richtig? Die müssen quasi die ganzen Hotelzimmer, die ganze Scheiße aus den Hotels... Super, super.
Wäre schwer im Sand eine Kanalisation zu bauen, also wenn die so geschiss alles bauen können, dann würde ich erwarten, so was basic-mäßiges wie eine Kanalisation bekommt man da auch hin.
Woher haben die eigentlich...
Woher haben die eigentlich das Geld? Ich meine, so groß sind die doch gar nicht, oder?
Alles Öl. Ja, das dachte ich mir, aber so groß sind die doch gar nicht. Also die haben im Prinzip Dubai und drumherum ist alles Öl, oder was?
Was haben die eigentlich hier gebaut? Ich meine, diese Sachen sehen gut aus aus dem Raum aus, aber was sind die wirklich, von nah und persönlich?
Oh, und es gibt auch eine Monorail in der Mitte.
post
ich kann mich nur an irish und hannah erinnern in wettbewerb 4
ist pepega
stimmte ich glaube er ist natürlich recker den man gespielt hat in
battlefield 4
leckbrenn hieß man in battlefield 3
der recker hieß man in battlefield 4
dritter welt kriegt man wieder was ganz neues
jetzt jetzt jetzt fehlt bloß noch
russ russland versus u.s.
dann hätten wir alle battlefield story klischees
das ist kein trailer das ist irgendwie ein short
kurzfilm für die battlefield
hört sich an wie ich
russland natürlich russland versus u.s.
was sonst immer der gleiche schilder
haus zu realisieren
Ah, Wettereffekte. Gut, gut. Haben wir ja im Trailer schon immer gezeigt bekommen.
What is happening?
Erstmal one man alles wegmachen.
Mein Cool inszeniert ist es ja schon.
Ah, guck mal, da ist ein Heli. Zufälligerweise liegt da ein RPG.
Na, noch mal Glück gehabt und jetzt 360. Wie? Nicht? Das ist aber unrealistisch.
Also ich hätte jetzt eigentlich einen 360 RPG Heli-Sniper erwartet.
Ja, er klang ja von Anfang an. What the fuck, macht sein Sohn jetzt random da?
Wie kommt der da hin?
Okay, das ist jetzt Grund dafür, dass Daddy jetzt richtig fertig macht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, die bringen doch keine Kinder um.
Weggesniped. Richtig geil gestellts mit der Sniper, aber dann mit dem offenen Rücken
gestanden und sich vom Heli wegbashing lassen. Und jetzt 360 RPG, jawoll. So muss das sein.
Der Dino ist aus Battlefield 3. Moment, Moment. Das Kind nennt seinen Vater Irish? Ernsthaft?
Ja, ist klar. Ich bin kurz davor erschossen zu werden und mein Vater ist am Starten. Ich
sag nicht Papa, sondern ich sag Irish. Genau, alles klar.
So mal Irish doch sein Codename ist, der Typ weiß doch gar nicht so. Oder? Hätte ich jetzt
erwartet. Das ist der Onkel. Hörst du mal. Alles mitgekriegt. Message sent. Das erinnert
mich voll an den ersten. Alles klar. Okay, geht, geht, geht durchaus durch. Einmal gespannt
was sonst noch für Kurzfilme geben wird. Sonderlich viel von der Story hat man nicht
mitbekommen. Das ist Message sent. Das hat mich ein bisschen an den ersten Overwatch
Kurzfilme erinnert, falls ihr jemand gesehen habt. Wo dann Winston am Ende auch auf diesen
Overwatch Call Knopf drückt. Das war natürlich komplett anderer Style. Okay, ja mal schauen.
Was haben wir denn Story technisch erfahren? Irish ist jetzt irgendwie so Art Söldner
oder sowas. Stell es da rum und basht Leute. Mehr habe ich da jetzt nicht ausverstanden.
Ah ja, Russen versus Amis natürlich. Wer hätte auch was anderes erwartet in Battlefield?
Selbstverständlich. Ansonsten bin ich eigentlich genauso schlau und sie treffen sich in Door.
Ja, ansonsten bin ich genauso schlau wie vorher. Ja. Die No Pets sind keine Amis. Ja, das stimmt,
aber anscheinend ist es ja trotzdem wieder mit zwei Fraktionen und du kämpfst halt für
die eine oder für die andere. Was erzählen sie ansonsten mit Terroristen und Russen und
sonst was? No Pets sind ja so Art Söldner, die dann für wen auch immer am Start sind.
Max, das machst du noch mal immer gegen diese Perso-Filme bei U18 ganz einfach. Hier, so
sieht das normalerweise aus und das geht nicht. Du löscht das hier und sagst Embed und dann
geht es. Geht nicht immer. Ja, das ist korrekt. Es geht nicht immer. Ich weiß nicht, wann
es geht und wann es nicht geht. Ich vermute, das hängt mit dem Video-Encoding zusammen.
Ich weiß es nicht, genau. Geht nicht mehr. Wie gesagt, bei manchen Videos geht es, bei
manchen geht es nicht. Beim Battlefield Gameplay Trailer geht es zum Beispiel nicht. Nein,
YouTube-DL geht auch nicht. YouTube-DL kann seit einer Woche oder so auch keine Altersgeschützten
mehr runterladen. Das kann sein, weiß nicht. Ach, YouTube-DLP kann das, okay. Mit Additional
Features, das muss ich mir später mal angucken. Exquisite Chat. Ist das nicht verboten? Spinepring
ist echt ein bisschen stinkig, dass ich den Termin verpasst habe. Ich muss Ende des Jahres
meinen Personalausweis verlängern lassen und da muss ich jetzt Fingerabdrücke abgeben.
Ich will eigentlich keine Fingerabdrücke abgeben. Beim Reisepass muss man es glaube
ich schon machen, aber ich will meine Fingerabdrücke nicht irgendwie in der Cloud speichern lassen.
Das nervt mich richtig, aber es geht wohl nicht anders. Also man kann keinen Ausweis
mehr jetzt machen ohne Fingerabdrücke. Ich weiß, im Reisepass sind die schon länger
drin, aber es ist mir doch egal. Nein, nein, nein, das ist nicht optional. Das ist Pflicht
seit August. Seit August ist das Pflicht. Ja, da habe ich ehrlich gesagt gar keinen
Bock drauf. So, mein neuer Smart Home Server. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich kenne ihn nicht,
das Video wurde mir vorhin empfohlen. Gucken wir uns das mal an. Neuer Smart Home Server.
So und ich gehe davon aus, dass die negativ Dislikes Leute sind, die prinzipiell alles
Disliken was Leute daheim bauen. Du hast so Leute, das sehe ich auch bei meinen Serverraum
Videos und sonst wie. Da hast du immer Leute, die in den Kommentare schreiben, haha Max,
lass das das nächste Mal den Profi machen. Dislike. So Leute hast du immer, die alles
schlecht finden, wenn sie es nicht selbst gemacht haben. Und selbst dann, wenn sie es
selbst gemacht hätten und man würde es ihnen zeigen, würden sie es auch schlecht finden,
wenn sie nicht wüssten, dass es von ihnen ist. Oder bevor du zum Ausweis machen gehst
Kleber auf die Finger schmieren. Kann man das irgendwie faken? Geht das? Ist das erlaubt?
Okay. Hey Leute und herzlich willkommen zu diesem neuen Video. Heute ist es soweit,
mein Server Rack wird mal ein bisschen geupgraded. So ist gut. Alles weitere und was genau passiert
nach dem Intro. Viel Spaß. Server Rack updaten. Home Assistant, Poggers. Das ganze hat auch
super funktioniert und ist natürlich auch relativ effizient. Problem an der Sache ist
nur, dass mittlerweile einige Services hinzugekommen sind, wie zum Beispiel ein Plex Server. Plex
ist auch so ein Ding. Ich verstehe nicht die Anwendungszweck von einem Plex Server. Also
ich weiß, was man damit macht. Man streamt damit Filme. Aber warum? Warum macht man das?
Das ist doch eigentlich nur für Leute, die sich die Sachen über Torrent oder Usenet
oder sonst was ziehen. Weil wenn ich Netflix oder Amazon oder sonst was habe, dann gucke
ich das direkt über die App von denen und alles andere. Also Plex ist doch eigentlich
nur für Leute, die irgendwie eine große, sagen wir mal, Sicherheitskopien Bibliothek
haben oder? Aber ich lade mir gar keine Filme mehr runter und speichere auch keine Filme
mehr unten. Warum sollte ich denn Terabyteweise für irgendwelche Filme offline haben, wenn
ich die einfach online streamen kann? Das verstehe ich nicht. Gibt halt so Qualitätsfetischisten.
Also die meisten neuen Amazon Sachen kriegst du komplett in 4K sogar teilweise mit HDR
oder Amazon. Egal, ich habe es für mich zumindest noch nicht so genau verstanden, wozu man das
braucht. Und ich möchte nicht, dass es bei meinem Smartphone irgendwann mal Verzögerungen
gibt, einfach aus dem Grund, dass da gerade jemand über meinen Plex Server sich Serien
anschaut. Aus diesem Grund und natürlich auch, da ich eine Serie gemacht habe, wie
ihr Home Assistant auf einem Raspberry Pi installieren könnt, Link übrigens unten
in der Videobeschreibung, werde ich in diesem Video Home Assistant komplett auf einem Raspberry
Pi aufsetzen, das Ganze in meinen Server rack integrieren und dabei das Ganze auch nochmal
aufsetzen. Ich will keine Home Assistant installieren, er macht ja auch gar nicht. Wir kriegen keine
Home Assistant Installation gezeigt, weil das wäre mega langweilig. Ausräumen. Hab
ich schon viel zu oft gemacht. So ich habe jetzt angefangen, weil ich das System vorzureiten
werde. Ich werde nicht nur Home Assistant darauf installieren, sondern gleichzeitig
das ganze System auch noch auf einer SSD aufbauen. Ja, das ist auch das einzig sinnvolle Mikro
SD und Home Assistant Islam as fuck. Das Ganze natürlich möglichst 24-7 laufen lassen können,
ohne dass irgendwann meine SD-Karte abschmiert. Mittlerweile ist es also soweit, Home Assistant
ist installiert. Ist das so eine 1&1 Fritzbox? Also so eine 1&1, diese Fritzbox gebrandet
von Unity Media ist das doch, oder? SSD ist aufgesetzt, auch wenn das Ganze super stressig
war, da SSDs mit dem Raspberry Pi nicht zu 100% funktionieren, wenn man nicht die richtigen
SSD Adapter besitzt und Home Assistant supervise, also nicht das Betriebssystem, sondern wenn
man ein ganz normales Linux Betriebssystem nimmt und darauf Home Assistant installiert,
das man auch mit einer SSD nicht unterstützt. Somit habe ich jetzt Home Assistant OS, also
das Betriebssystem, auf einer SSD installiert und zum Laufen bekommen, um den USB Adapter
... Das ist auch die beste Variante, das habe ich auch mittlerweile, aber ich habe sie in
4M laufen. Also den Konbi-Stick für ZigBee zum Laufen zu bekommen, muss ich noch einen
USB-Verlängerungstecker verwenden, da ansonsten dieser Stick einfach nicht funktioniert hat.
Ja, das ist übrigens ein bekanntes Problem. Die ZigBee-Sticks haben, weil die glaube ich
auch 2,4 Gigahertz sind oder sowas, die haben echt Probleme, wenn die zu nah am Rechner
dran sind. Den ZigBee-Stick, wenn man den über einen USB-Verlängerungskabel nimmt und
ein bisschen eben dranlegt, dann funktioniert es, aber direkt ans Gehäuse gestöpselt funktioniert
es oftmals nicht. Das Problem hatte ich auch. Ich kann meine Tratt Free Bridge und meine
Philips Hue Bridge endlich vom Strom nehmen, denn jetzt kann ich alle Geräte direkt über
den Konbi-Stick ansprechen. Was jetzt noch über bleibt, ist mein Server-Rack einzuräumen,
umzubauen und dann den Raspberry Pi auch noch da rein zu integrieren. Ja, zeig mal her, Server-Rack.
Moment, was hat er da für ein Gehäuse gehabt am Start? Ah, das ist irgendein fettes, mit
Hotswap-Dingern. Kennt man da irgendwas? Das ist zumindest viel Strom. Warum legt er den
Raspberry Pi nicht einfach in die 4HE-Kiste rein? Dann sieht es von außen cooler aus
und erspart trotzdem Strom. Wenn nicht, das wäre eine gute Idee. Ich hecke an meinem Getränk
hier nebendran. Soll ich auch mal da sein Nass drin stehen? Dann kommt irgendwie ein
neuer. Was ist denn das? HP Pro? Was ist das Pro Safe? Netgear, oder? Switch. Aber zumindest
ordentlich verkabelt. Sieht besser aus als bei mir. So, und dann möchte ich auch direkt
die Gelegenheit nutzen und euch mal eine aktualisierte Tour durch mein Server-Rack geben. Fangen
von oben links an. Hier steht mein Backup-Server. Dieser sichert alle Daten von meinem Hauptserver
und ist mit einer 10TB Festplatte bestückt. Daneben haben wir einen HOMATIC Access Point,
der steht hier einfach nur rum, weil ich aktuell keine HOMATIC-Geräte angeschlossen habe und
falls ich da... Ah, HOMATIC ist ja auch Paints-Champ.... wieder anschließen möchte, liegt der hier
eben noch. Daneben haben wir eine USB, die das Rack im Zweifel noch mit Strom versorgen
kann. Damit, damit hatte ich auch meine Probleme. Mittlerweile ist meine USB nicht mehr in Betrieb,
ne? Die hat ja... Meine USB war ja der Meinung, selbst wenn da Strom da ist, aber die Batterie
kaputt, das ganze Rack auszuschalten. Also, nope.... irgendein Stromausfall sein sollte.
Darunter mein Switch, der aktuell nicht voll bestückt ist, sondern eben nur hier der erste
Teil. Da ich hier aber einige neue Geräte anschließe, habe ich eben hier noch ein paar
Spare-Ports frei. Direkt unter den Netzwerkkabeln versteckt sich meine Raspberry Pi 4. Das ist
jetzt der neue Smart Home Core, sei das mal. Wie hat er den gemountet? Ist der in natürlich
Netzwerk per... Wie hat er... Ah, das ist was 3D-gedrucktes, guck mal. 3D-gedrucktes Pi
Rack-Mount. Das finde ich cool. Moment, das muss ich mal kurz... Da muss ich mal kurz
checken. Singiverse. Pi-Rack.
Tatsächlich. Guck mal hier. Wobei mich so ein Single-Mount-Ding auch... Hier! Nee,
das ist ein fertiger... Oder ist das auch 3D-druckt hier? Das ist nicht 3D-druckt. Doch, das ist
auch 3D-druckt. Cool. Hast du das nicht schon mal gesucht? Doch,
das kommt mir bekannt vor. Habe ich aber noch nicht gemacht. Nice, ich glaube so was drücke
ich mir später mal aus. Oder das da. Das ist natürlich auch nice. Wie druckt man das
aus? Nicht im Ganzen, ne? Das druckt man... Ah, Einzel. Weil so viele Raspberry-Pis hab
ich gar nicht. Ich habe im Serverraum einen stehen und der ist für den Drucker. So. Aber
das finde ich schon mal schön gemacht. Per USB ist die SSD angeschlossen. Das ist das
Kabel hier und hier oben seht ihr... Es waggelt aber ein bisschen, ne? Und hier rechts daneben
ist das USB-Verlängerungskabel, welches einmal nach hier oben geht und hier aktuell noch
hier frei hängen. SIGMI-Stick, Konbi. Der Konbi-Stick, der dann die ganze Geräte steuern
kann. Ist ja neu, ich glaube sogar der Zweier ist das. Hier haben wir dann noch einmal USB-C.
Damit wird der Raspberry-Pi mit Strom versorgt. Das ganze befindet sich in einem selbstgedruckten
Gehäuse. Link dazu packe ich euch unten in die Schreibung, wenn ihr euch das selber
mal auf... Das ist das, wo dann manche Leute für negative Kommentare geben. Du hast auf
YouTube eh so viele überhebliche Kommentareschreiber. So nach dem Motto, haha Max, lass das mal
ein Profi machen. Oder bei ihm schreibt dann jemand in die Kommentare, äh Dislike, wer
ist du mal mein Azubi, der hätt ich dich damit durchfallen lassen, haha oder irgendwie
sowas. Es gibt so viele, es ist unglaublich wie viele vollen Spaßen es auf YouTube gibt.
Also, wie gesagt, ich sag das jetzt explizit nicht, ja? Ich find das gut, wie er das gemacht
hat. Zuletzt für Ausbau und darunter dann meinen aktuellen Server. Das ist ein NAS,
wo aber auch eben einige Services drauf laufen. Eine 4HE-Kiste, so muss das sein. Und noch
ein paar andere Dienste. Wenn der Gram nicht so strompfressend wäre, hätt ich meine 4HE-Kiste
auch noch im Einsatz. Vorher mein Home Assistant drauf, was ich jetzt eben auf den Raspberry
Pi migriert habe. An Festplatten hab ich hier zwei 10TB Festplatten, zwei SSDs und
eine 4TB Festplatte für Filme und Serien und auch noch ein paar Backups von meinen PCs.
Das Ganze ist auf Schienen. Die meisten seisen ihren HomeSoft, das stimmt. Ich hab ja auch
damals richtig fettes Ding gebaut, als ich hier den Raum zuerst ausgestattet hab und
bis ich jetzt zum Schluss gekommen bin, total oversized, jetzt bin ich bei einem Low-Power-Intel-Quad-Core,
also bei so einem 8 Watt Eidl-Ding und hat kaum Schnittstellen, PCIe Express, aber reicht
für das, was ich machen will und braucht irgendwie ein Drittel an Strom. Jetzt ist direkt wie
früher Xeroxino, danke schön, 24 Monate Subscription hier, Hypersubscriptions hier, wenn ich mal
daran arbeiten möchte. Und hier unten drunter ist ein, ich sag mal, Fehlkauf von mir, das
ist ein Switch, den ich vorher verwendet habe. Nein, da gibt es keine Single-Board-Computer
mit mehr als einem SATA-Port. Ja, wie gesagt, du kriegst, also die Low-Power-Intel X86-Kisten
kriegst du mit mehreren SATA-Ports und die brauchen auch nicht wirklich viel mehr als
einen Raspberry Pi 4. Mit 48 Ports, allerdings ist der ultra laut und deswegen für meine
Zwecke eigentlich nicht geeignet, denn wenn ich hier im Normalfall die Türe schließe,
ist es von der Lautstärke her eigentlich relativ leise, man hört die Lüfter hier leicht
sohnen, aber es ist eben kein störendes Geräusch, wohingegen dieser Switch... Ich glaube, dieses
Rack, das ist das, was ich mir ursprünglich auch mal bestellen wollte, was UPS mit zerbrochenem
Glas geliefert hat, wo ich dann extra noch diesen Paypal-Käufer-Klärungsservice benutzen
musste, wo sich der Shop auf am letzten Tag gemeldet hat und hat gemeint, zurückschicken
ist zu teuer, behalts einfach. Jetzt hatte ich irgendwie jetzt ein Jahr in meiner Garage
ein Rack rumstehen mit kaputtem Glas. Eben einfach viel zu laut war. So und das war's
von meiner kleinen Tour und meinem Umbau mit dem Raspberry Pi. Ich hoffe, es konnte einigen
von euch helfen, wenn ihr mal... Ich finde, das hat er doch echt gut gemacht, ich weiß
gar nicht, was man da jetzt negativ bewerten sollte. Gucken wir uns mal die Eukommens an.
Brauchst du die Tür unbedingt? Nö. Aber mein jetziges Rack gefällt mir eh besser,
weil es offen ist. Ich mein, ich hab ja den Vorteil von... Ich hab ja den Vorteil, dass
ich einen eigenen Raum habe. Ich hab ja den Vorteil, dass ich einen eigenen Raum habe und
da ist so ein Rack, was offen ist, eigentlich viel, viel praktischer. Da kommt man nämlich
wenigstens überall dran von der Seite. Ja, also das verstehe ich nicht, warum die hier
großartig disliked haben, aber das ist ein gutes Video von ihm. Mal gucken, was die Leute
wieder flämen. Richtig gut, gutes Video. Was ist das für ein Typ wieder? Alter! Jutz,
es geht so viel. Was ein Vogel, ja. Der Typ zeigt sein Server-Rack. Wo ist das Problem?
Das muss doch für den gar nicht... Du zeigst da irgendwas, was für niemand nützlich ist.
Der Switch ist zu laut. Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen,
Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen, bitte nicht die nächste Woche wieder. Hä? Alter, warum schreibt
man solche Comments? Sonst gehts dir aber gut, wenn dir das Video nicht passt. Ja, korrekt.
Keine Kritik, das ist doch keine Kritik. Das ist einfach sinnloses Gebäsche. Das ist
einfach sinnloses, sinnloses Gebäsche. Der Kritik wäre gewesen, wenn er zum Beispiel
geschrieben hätte, du hättest uns ja auch mal die Thingiverse Sachen verlinken können,
was man selbst ausdrucken kann oder so. Ok, das ist zum Beispiel sinnvolle Kritik. Jetzt
weiß der wenigstens auch, wo das Problem ist. Ok, das finde ich in Ordnung. Das finde
ich ja in Ordnung. Der schreibt wenigstens, was er für ein Problem hat. Ok, das kann ich
jetzt nachvollziehen. Lavas Lava Lampen. Da kann das Video nicht aufmachen, es buggt.
Diablo 4 Chefentwickler und mehr von Blizzard. Leute, ich hab jetzt tatsächlich die Diablo
Resurrected, oder wie das Ding genau heißt, Alpha gespielt, Beta, Beta Test gespielt.
Ich hab ja gesagt auf Twitter, ich kauf mir das nicht, aber ich hab durch, ähm, wie heißt
das, Drops, den Kram bekommen. Das erste, was ich hatte, ist 9 Charge leveled auf 6,
Server gecrasht, Charles wieder 1. Aber ansonsten muss ich sagen, es ist echt ganz gut umgesetzt
bis jetzt. Switch Drops, ja. Du musst 2,5 Stunden Diablo Resurrected gucken, dann kriegst
du den Kram als Drop. Geht das noch? Wahrscheinlich. Drops. Twitch.
Du musst aber deinen Account verknüpfen, dass das geht. Ja. Oh. Nein. Ist nicht mehr,
ist nicht mehr aktiv. So, schauen wir mal. Hab ich die Musik viel zu laut gehabt. Schauen
wir mal. Eigentlich interessiert mich nichts davon. Eigentlich interessiert mich nichts
davon. RIP Gamestar. So, was haben wir ansonsten? Battlefield 3 Top Plays, ja, das muss mal wieder
sein. Log Picking Lawyer, Twitch Meter, Browser DevTools, das ist hier Big Brain Content wieder.
Leute, wir gucken jetzt, wir gucken jetzt die DevTools, 9 Minuten 95, danach guckt man
Battlefield 3 und dann muss ich mal Epopupu machen. Scammers, es gibt keine Scammers im
Internet. Fake News. Ich hab noch nie einen Scammers im Internet gesehen. Die ganzen indischen
Microsoft Mitarbeiter sind auch komplett legit.
Das stimmt.
Natürlich, was sonst? Was sonst?
Ich würde sogar sagen, dass Firefox, was DevTools angeht, noch einen kleinen Vorteil, also
eines der wenigen Sachen, die Firefox noch versus Chrome hat.
Dazu, dazu, Moment, Moment, Moment. Moment, das muss, das verwende ich so. Ich hab einen
Pen, keine Ahnung. Ich hab meins vor über einem Jahr gekauft. Es gibt Nachfolger davon,
es gibt Nachfolgerboards davon, muss man gucken.
Ja, benutze ich auch viel zu wenig. Es ist eigentlich richtig praktisch.
Ja, benutze ich auch nicht.
Okay, dann ist Facebook zu 90% rot. Also Facebook lädt ja mittlerweile, keine Ahnung,
30 MB JavaScript oder so, bevor die Seite überhaupt funktioniert. Und wer es mir nicht glaubt,
passt mal auf, ich zeige euch das, das stimmt. Das ist richtig krass. Facebook. So, mal laden
ohne, ohne Cache. Na gut, ich muss eingeloggt sein dafür. Guck mal, jetzt haben wir nur,
okay, ich brauch mal eine Facebook-Seite. Wer hat eine Facebook-Seite? Ah, guck mal,
ich. Haha. So, und jetzt das Ganze, und jetzt das Ganze ohne Cache. Okay, 10 MB, sind nur
10 MB, 10 MB. Die haben das aber schon Hardcore optimiert. Sind nur 10 MB. Es ist weniger
geworden. Aber trotzdem ganz schön viel.
Ja, das kenn ich. Und wenn das geht, wusste ich gar nicht, dass das funktioniert. Ich dachte,
das geht nur, wenn man jQuery verwendet. Und das ist select all, das wusste ich auch noch
nicht. Ich dachte, man muss dann sagen, document select query, bla, bla, bla, bla. Ja. Ach.
Das wusste ich auch noch nicht. Ach. Das wusste ich nie.
Ich copy paste immer unten in diese Command-Line rein. Und Firefox erlaubt mir das neuerdings
nicht. Du sagst erst mal, bitte Paste Enable machen. Ich erlaube kein Copy Paste. Das ist
tatsächlich richtig praktisch. Moment, sehe ich das richtig mit? Man kann const-Variable
neu deklarieren mit, hä? Okay. JavaScript, Dinge. Ach. Das ist ja cool. Da kann ich
indirekt den Selector kopieren, der das Ding dann später, wo ich das dann später auswählen
kann. Ich habe die ganze Zeit dafür so einen Addon verwendet für Chrome, dass die Tasten,
dass die Interaktion mit der Webseite aufzeichnen kann. Aber das ist ja nice, wusste ich gar
nicht, dass das da dabei ist. Richtig high IQ Content hier.
Das kenne ich. Das kenne ich, das kenne ich. Ja, der Typ macht echt gute Videos, von dem
kannst du dir fast jedes einzelne Video geben. Und jetzt das, what the fuck, was, was bin
ich hier sehend? CSS-Animation, ne, das ist mir eh zu hoch. CSS-Animation kriege ich eh
nicht gebacken. Da bin ich zu lauf, Brains, für...
Oh, das ist praktisch. Das ist tatsächlich sehr, jetzt wird's aber advanced. Alter, was
denn jetzt los? Also ich finde es ja schon cool, dass man das überhaupt angezeigt bekommen
kann, wo was aufhört. Was zum... Was da alles eingebaut ist? Das habe ich noch nie im Leben
gesehen. What the fuck? Was sich alles gibt.
Ja, das kenne ich, okay. Das weiß ich, dass es funktioniert. Leider hat dieser Mobile-Sachen
nichts mit dem zu tun, wie Safari die Sachen anzeigt, weil Safari einfach nur der Sack
ist. Du kannst da auch deinen CSS zusammenklicken, doch?
Ja. Lighthouse haben sie doch letztens mal geflamed, weil das irgendwas gemacht hat,
was man nicht machen sollte. Ich weiß nicht mehr, was das war. Ich weiß nur noch, dass
Lighthouse übelstens Geflame abbekommen hat, mal vor einem Jahr oder so. Ich weiß aber
nicht mehr, warum... Es war noch Zeiten, wo du einfach auf eine
Webseite gegangen bist und die Webseite ist geladen und hat sie direkt angezeigt. Heute
lädt das erstmal 30 Milliarden Javascript-Sachen runter und dann brauchst du das Javascript,
um das HTML zu erzeugen, was du siehst. Stimmt, ja genau, weil die empfohlen haben,
irgendwelche Frameworks nicht zu verwenden. Stimmt, ich glaube, das war es. Ja, genau.
Pepo-Fed-Website. Angular ist das plotetste von allen. Was?
Alter, haben wir noch nie was von gehört. Ah, hier. Das ist Kokona-Style. Erstmal Medikamente
bei Amazon. Die Amis haben ja auch ihre Schmerztabletten-Dinger. Da haben die immer so einen 5000-Tabletten-Riesen-Kübel,
so nach dem Motto, ich brauche Schmerztabletten. Ah, yes.
Ja, das war noch Zeiten, wo Webseiten einfach HTML war. Heute sieht eine Webseite so aus.
Mein Code create nie Memory Leaks. Habt ihr schon jemals in meinem Stream gesehen, dass
ich irgendwo mal einen Memory Leak produziert habe? Kann überhaupt nicht sein. Mein neues
Gift-Tool. Da habe nicht ich das Memory Leak produziert, sondern FFmpeg. Kann ich ja nichts
tun. Okay, das ist mir jetzt zu big brain. Das ist jetzt zu big brain. Echt nicht.
Das ist Werbung. Werbung. Gut, das ist Werbung. Der muss gucken, dass er Geld verdient. So
Leute, jetzt. Bam. Eine Runde Battlefield-Top-Plays. Das muss jetzt einfach noch sein. Das muss
mir jetzt noch geben. 11 Minuten Battlefield-Top-Plays. Nein, wir gucken uns jetzt nicht die Lava-Lampen
an. Wobei, die gehen nur drei Minuten. Das können wir gucken. Also, Chat, was ist los
mit den Lava-Lampen? Warum sollen wir uns die Lava-Lampen ansehen? Das stimmt. Random
Numbergenerator sind in der Regel nicht sonderlich random. Zumindest, wenn man den Seed kennt.
Was haben die denn? Was haben die denn für komischen Sound? Der Preis-Champ geht auch
durch Cloudflare. Und dann kam Let's Encrypt.
Die wollen uns nicht wirklich erzählen, dass Cloudflare den Random Number aus Lava-Lampen
füttert, oder? Warum nimmt man da nicht irgendwelche Partikel in der Atmosphäre oder sowas?
Irgendwelches Rauschen? Wirklich? Ich meine, die Idee ist schon richtig
cool. Das ist eigentlich ne richtig geile Idee. Eigentlich ne coole Idee. Okay, aber die
nehmen das auch nicht für jede Random Number. Die nehmen das als Seed. Also sprich, die
nehmen schon nen schnellen Pseudo-Random-Generator, aber die sieden das mit nem echten Random.
Das ist natürlich ne coole Idee, das mit so zu machen. Ja, genau. Einfach die Pixel nehmen
und irgendwie Char 256, was auch immer, draus machen. Ja, das ist ne richtig coole Idee.
Das macht Random Org auch. Ich dachte, Random Org macht irgendwelche atmosphärischen, irgendwelches
Rauschen. Frag mich nicht. Ich wusste nicht, dass Random Org das mit Lava-Lampen macht.
Genau, Radio-Empfänger. Genau, genau. Irgendwelches Rauschen in der Atmosphäre oder so macht Random
Org. Das ist ne richtig coole Idee. Oh, Radioactive.
Finish ist ne coole Idee.
Ich finde die Idee recht cool.
Ist eigentlich ne coole Idee. Ich mein, es würde wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich reicht
fast alles, was du random aufnehmen kannst. Wenn du ne Wiese aufnimmst, wo die Grashalme
wackeln durch den Wind oder so. Wahrscheinlich reicht schon ne Kreuzung mit Autos und Bäume,
wo die Blätter wackeln und so. Aber das ist natürlich richtig geil. Das ist komplette
Randomness. Was hat so ne Lava-Lampe? 100 Watt pro Lava-Lampe? Kein Schimmer. Weiß ich
nicht. So, jetzt Runde Battlefield 3. Poggers. Er wieder. Er wieder. Natürlich Metro-M16.
Oh. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Das gibt huge, huge bash jetzt. Sag mal, sind die, sag mal, seid
ihr komplett Brain AFK oder was? Was ist mit euch los? Pepega Gegner, ey. Das sind, das
waren die Tests für die Battlefield 2042 Bots. Die haben in Wirklichkeit grad den Botcode
getestet fürs nächste Battlefield. Der Amtrak war auch so ein OP Ding. Leider, leider hast
du einen gebraucht, der sich aufopfert und fährt. Nice Heli Snipes. Oh, Doppel Heli Snipes.
Collateral Heli Snipes. Und jetzt Heli klauen. Poggers, so muss das sein. Weiß man schon
was über SPMM und Battlefield 2042? Man weiß, dass man nichts weiß. Das Einzige, was vermutet
wird, wo sie glaub ich auch was zugesagt haben, ist, dass die kein übergreifendes Skill-Base-Matchmaking
machen, sondern wenn du in den Server joinst, werden quasi sowas wie Auto-Balancing passieren
anhand deiner globalen Stats. Das heißt, das Server selbst wird etwas besser balanced.
Mal gucken, wie krass das am Ende ausfallen wird. Es ist ein bisschen wie die Auto-Balancer,
die es jetzt schon gibt, die halt am Ende eine Runde gucken, wer hat die meisten Punkte
und sortiert es dann so, dass es im Durchschnitt wieder stimmt.
Redet er heute gar nicht? Das wäre mir sogar fast lieber.
Predicted. Predicted. Ganz klar, dass da jetzt der Chat reinfliegt. Predicted. Natürlich,
was sonst? Calculated. Calculated. Voll Anfang an. What? Okay, das war äußerst glücklich.
Oh, da stehen sie. Lasst sie sprayen. Alter, lasst sie sich wegsprayen. Die haben sich
hart wegsprayen lassen gerade. Okay, da trifft den Heli jetzt. Oder es fliegt ein Jet rein
oder sowas. Bam, nee, nice. Und noch den Hitch. Jawoll. Oh nee, nee, ich dachte, er trifft
den Chat noch. Ja. Ich kriege die Dinger aus. Ja. Die halten generell Equipment in
Battlefield 3 hält unglaublich viel aus. Oder ist schwer zu hitten? Und der hittet
jetzt. Boah. Calculated. Ganz klar. Ist klar. Da hat er aber gut gepasst dazu. Zack.
Was? Ich wollte gerade sagen, wie hat es der Typ geschafft, ihn nicht zu killen, von
hinten leben? Ah, er wieder. Er wieder. Jetzt kommen wieder irgendwelche Metro-Smoked. Oh,
da stehen sie, Alter. Die lassen sich so wegklatschen. Gregs beste. Gregs beste, jawoll. Bam.
Du siehst den Ausgabe.
Okay, so hat die Waffe kaum einer gesp- Oh, wie sie es nicht checken. Alter, wie sie es
nicht checken. Wie sie es nicht kapieren. Lull. Richtige Low-Brain, Leute. Boah. Also
eins muss man sagen, die G18, das ist echt mega OP in dem Game. Aber ich spiele trotzdem
lieber Gregs. Gregs beste. Da kommt er halt vor. Kennst du den Greg-Song, ne?
Oh, nice, nice, nice. Jetzt sitzen sie wieder am Arsch der Welt rum und snipen und sonst-
Der Typ wieder. Der macht doch nichts anderes mit dem ganzen Tag dort auf dieser. Von dem
haben wir schon 50 Clips gesehen, die gleiche Pose auf der gleichen Map. Der macht echt
sein Leben lang nichts anderes, als auf der einen Pose zu stehen und in die eine Richtung
zu snipen. Nice, doppelt. Triple. Hitmarker. Ne. Nice. Also das sind Sniping Clips, damit
kann ich nichts anfangen. Ganz ehrlich, so cool die Dinger sind, aber das sind meistens
Sniper, die null zur Runde beitragen. Es ist ja ganz cool, wenn der Firestorm oder Caspian
Border oder sonst wie 20 Minuten rumstehst und zwei Kills machst, aber das bringt halt
gar nichts. Das ist komplett useless, die paar Kills, die die Leute dann machen die
Runde. Dann sind wir Leute, die aktiv- Ich sag euch, je nachdem wie gut das wird mit
Gadgets ausrüsten und jeder kann sich heilen und sonst wie, was, die ganzen Sniper ey,
die ganzen Rumlieger, No Scoper und Hard Scoper, das wird die Pest im Battlefield 2042, wenn
da nicht irgendwas kommt, was da einschränkt. Das sind dann 80% Sniper die Runde und du
kannst auch nicht mal Sniper Limit machen, außer du baust den Portal selbst was zusammen.
Ey, das ist doch gestellt, oder? Das ist doch gestellt. Das kann mir doch keiner erzählen,
dass der Typ da so random einfach nur immer gegenüberrum schwebt. Warum sollte der das
denn machen, außer er will gesniped werden?
Check out this clip from an intense close quarters streak on Nosha Canals in the AA gun.
It's a bit of a rampage from killed in action, getting behind the enemy players as they're
all pinned up against this wall.
Oh, wie sie sich wegspringen lassen.
Erstmal ein Smoke rein, jawoll.
Okay, der schießt einfach immer auf die gleiche Stelle und die Leute rennen weiterhin raus.
WTF? Alter! Das ist wieder Bot Simulation für Battlefield 2042.
WTF? Ah, der Smoke. Der Smoke. Das ist das Beste. Das ist, das ist geil, wenn er seine
Smoke-Launcher-Kills macht.
How many, how many this time, come on.
Direct Implex-Boss. Und die checken es wieder durch.
Look.
Go on, someone. Go on your face.
Da ist er. Oh nein. Ausgerechnet.
Hahaha, die Gegner. Null.
Die Gegner.
Okay, die ist schön weg. Alter!
Wie low-brain. Wie low-brain kann man sein?
WTF? Ultra low-brain.
Jutsch. Jutsch quali.
Ja, so ist das halt gewesen in Battlefield 3. Tot, retz, tot, retz, tot, retz, tot, retz.
Aber du musst einfach ein bisschen warten, wenn du wiederbelebt wirst. Einfach ein bisschen
warten.
So, ja, nee, genau. Kannst du euch noch ein bisschen lang...
Nicht bewegen. Einfach nicht bewegen. Einfach nicht bewegen und Spawn-Immunity-Klitschen.
Guck, der bewegt sich zu früh. Den Fehler habe ich auch lange gemacht. Einfach nichts
machen.
Dann bist du Spawn-Immune.
Na klar.
GUNMASTER war Pock.
Das einzige, was ich ein bisschen doof fand, das forcierte Wechsel der Waffen in GUNMASTER.
Ich hätte es besser gefunden, man muss den Knopf drücken zum Switchen, weil manchmal
war es sehr unglücklich, wie er die Waffe geswitcht hat nach einem Kill.
Sie könnten ja auch sagen, der Kill zählt da nicht, wenn man nicht switcht.
Gaben. Der echte. Der Trick ist sofort auch schon wieder hinlegen, ach war das so.
Ah. Der Klassiker.
Gaben-Zock-Battlefield-Reiher. Sauer-Reiher soll lieber Haftpfeffer machen.
Sehr gut.
Logitech.
Bam.
Leute. Ich habe Hunger. Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Ist da Frazier am Start? Chat? Nee.
Ist da Frazier da? Zeig mal her. Nein, war schon ewig nicht mehr on.
So kann ich jemand hosten? Zeig mal kurz hier gucken.
Nope. Keiner da.
Heute Abend wieder Hetznapp. Ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher.
Ich muss das noch ein bisschen vorbereiten und ich glaube, ich habe noch nicht genug
dafür gemacht.
Und ich muss noch das Stellenanzeigen-Video fertig aufnehmen.
Leute. Ich gehe jetzt. Ich muss aufs Klo.
Und Hunger habe ich auch. Keine Kombination, mit der man noch lange
streamen kann.
Also Leute. Wir sehen uns. Bis dann. C U.